Donald Trump appeared in court today in
Washington D.C he pleaded not guilty to
the conspiracy charges he's been
threatened with remand into custody
pre-trial confinement if he communicates
with any of the Witnesses in the case he
agreed to these terms and then he
carried on his merry way and I will just
say in the context of this story the
fact that they did not remind Trump into
custody proves it is a political sham
because anybody who did anything I mean
you know you know what no no not even
anything near let's if you stole a
diamond necklace and you owned a bunch
of jets they'd be like okay this is a
Flight Risk and you have buildings in
foreign countries you have properties
all over the world you own Golf Resorts
they'd be like this guy's a Flight Risk
they're accusing Donald Trump of trying
to overthrow the U.S government an
Insurrection a conspiracy to defraud the
U.S and they're like you're free to go
good sir just you know come back when we
need you they don't seriously think this
man did anything wrong it's political
we also got a bunch of other news my
friends Rhonda Santos says that he is
going to start um
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Save what he said
for when we get later in the show
because it's probably too soon in the
show to say exactly what Rhonda said to
said but let's just put it simply he
used a very graphic analogy uh a
metaphor for firing intelligence
agencies uh intelligence agents so uh
yeah he's very very serious on that and
then we got big news there's a leaked
clip that came out from Tucker Carlson's
show with uh the former Chief of Police
with the Capitol Police where he
basically says it looks like January 6
was a cover-up someone may have wanted
this to happen and he was the guy in
charge basically saying he was being
obstructed so we're going to talk about
all of that before we do my friends head
over to castbrew.com and buy our coffee
to support the show you can join the
cast Brew Coffee Club you'll get three
bags per month we had a whole bunch of
new flavors we got the Sleepy Joe decaf
maybe you saw Joe Biden today was
selling that mug with him with Gloria
for some reason you bought that mug you
can pour sleepy Joe decath into it
wouldn't that be fun but when you buy
from Castro you are helping to support
us we sponsor ourselves this is our
company and so everything you know we we
get from selling this product goes
toward just you know helping keep things
running but you can also support us
directly by going to timcast.com
clicking join us becoming a member and
you'll get access to our uncensored
members only shows we're gonna have one
for you tonight at 10 pm it's gonna be a
lot of fun and as a member you actually
get a chance to call in and talk to us
and our guest by submitting questions we
then choose four or five every night and
we take your question so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends take that URL
right now post it anywhere you can it's
the most effective way to help if you
can't become a member if you can't buy
our coffee at least you could do that
because that really really does up and I
really would appreciate it and uh
joining us today tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Liz wheeler hi
Tim thanks for having me absolutely who
are you what do you do I'm Liz wheeler I
host the Liz wheeler show you can find
it on Apple podcasts on Spotify anywhere
you find your podcast I also have a new
book coming out called hide your
children exposing the marxists behind
the attack on America's kids you can
find that at hideyourchildrenbook.com
that's a good name thanks you want to
know where I got that name actually from
that the video yeah the video
should have asked him though yeah he's
out there is it isn't he like kind of
right lane or something
right yeah yeah like I mean there's
another story a a woman in Portland got
uh mercilessly beaten by a homeless guy
now she's a republican surprise surprise
but uh thanks for hanging out yeah
thanks for having me Hannah Claire is
here hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm
back I'm a writer for timcast.com you
should follow them on all the social
medias and Ian's here well over running
in Crossland happy to be here on this
Thursday night awesome night Liz great
to see you again good to see you look
forward hearing about your book thank
you what's up Serge I love how in the
bottom of your shot there that carnivore
thing just this carnivore underneath
a carnivore snacks life is changing guys
we uh we went on Public Square the app
and we bought a bunch of jerky so we got
carnivore snacks and Anthem jerky and it
is all just some of the best jerky beef
and salt these are the ingredients it is
like slimy with beef fat it is the
greatest like man that is good stuff the
carnivore snacks it is literally a piece
of steak with fat on it yeah I pulled
one out last night during show and like
looked at anything like why is this beef
jerky white and bro I was like it's The
Fad it's the best part the most
delicious not expecting it's intense
it's super good for you yeah uh anyways
let's get started all right here's the
story ladies and gentlemen today Donald
Trump arrived in Washington DC pleaded
not guilty political reports Trump
pleads not guilty to charges that he
conspired to overturn the 2020 election
at the former president's arraignment
prosecutors and defense lawyers signaled
immediate disagreement over how quickly
he should stay in trial so my
understanding is I think that they have
it in here somewhere the next date will
be August 28th was that it did they even
how far down do I got to go for them to
confirm it but I'm pretty sure here we
go check Khan's first hearing was set
for August 28th before then prosecutors
and Trump's defense team were ordered to
submit briefs proposing a schedule for
the trial chitcon expects eight to set a
trial date at the August 28th hearing
Trump criticized Chicana in a social
media post a few hours before
calling her unfair so apparently the
reporting is that Jack Smith is trying
to try this extremely quickly saying we
need a speedy trial here probably
because the primaries are coming up and
uh you know there's another story we'll
get into Rhonda Santos debating Gavin
Newsom I kind of feel like that's what
the Deep state is hoping for Gavin
Newsom not Joe Biden and Rhonda Sanders
not Donald Trump I am not trying to
imply that either of them are working
for the Deep State or the intelligence
agencies I am saying that they don't
want a failing Joe Biden because he
can't win and they despise Donald Trump
so they're trying to get whatever they
can thus Jack Smith is like let's get
this speedy and and rushed through but
uh I wanna I'll add one thing before we
all just jump into the conversation
I think the fact that they did not
remind Trump to custody proves it is not
a legitimate criminal trial
and people can make the argument oh no
Trump's not a Flight Risk nobody thinks
he'll flee he's running for president
it's like okay fair point but they're
accusing him of trying to overthrow the
government that's what they're saying on
MSNBC this guy owns a 757 a Cessna
Citation he owns two helicopters he
apparently he probably has access to
more Jets than just those not to mention
being a billionaire he can easily
Charter a private jet if they
legitimately thought Trump was a threat
to democracy and that he was trying to
overthrow the government
how could they not order him to to be
remanded
it just makes me start to wonder like
who
are Service agents and where are their
loyalties you know what I mean like who
who do they think that they'll just be
like no no we won't let you flee if you
really wanted to I'm sure he could
figure it out uh the entire case against
Trump and I made this argument the other
night was it it's obviously intended to
destroy the pattern and uh momentum of
his campaign right Jack Smith was
happily investigating for years and then
all of a sudden he's ready and we have
to rush this prosecution doesn't seem
suspicious at all wait of course it's
complete convenience Trump could go to
his jumbo jet and say we're going to do
a route we have a scheduled rally in
insert City Milwaukee and then they all
get on the plane and then as soon as the
plane takes off he goes to the pilot and
says we're going the El Salvador and
then you know people could argue like oh
there's no Flight Plan he could just do
it they could if you just do it the
problem is if he left excuse me uh he
wouldn't be able to be president well of
course I know he doesn't want to burn
that bridge the sort of considerable
Flight Risk I I don't buy it they're
they're accusing Trump of some of the
most serious crime times in the history
of this country they are claiming that
he attempted to steal they're claiming
that he he called for an Insurrection to
Stage a coup on the capitol to to steal
power that is that is seditious they're
effectively arguing whether they didn't
charge him for uh charge him with it or
not seditious conspiracy and then being
like nah you're good go on home buddy I
don't I don't here's what I think though
I think that we're missing one little
point I agree with you that it's
obviously not serious charges if they
actually thought he was a threat they
would have kept him in pre-trial
detention just like they did with so
many of the January 6th exactly that
which I thought was setting a legal
precedent so that they could do this
with Trump I still think they're going
to I don't think that just because they
let him walk out today that that means
that they're not going to I think they
obviously want to put Trump in prison
because they despise Trump they think
it'll destroy his presidential campaign
but if you look at the Crux of what this
indictment from Jack Smith in is is it's
really against political speech it's a
violation of your First Amendment right
to have an opinion that is different
than the opinion of the Joe Biden
Administration which we can talk about
the trickle-down effects of that but I
think that they want to decriminalize
not just Trump's Free Speech they want
to criminalize us so how do they do that
well they wait until this story's passed
he tweets something they disagree with
they say it's you know ruining this case
they put him in pre-trial detention
because they want some crazed Trump
supporter to commit an act of violence
so that they can say well it's not just
it's not just a crime when Trump says
this it's a crime when all you all say
this and we're gonna crack down on you I
think there could be a component to that
I think part of the Free Speech angle or
the the criticism of political speech is
that they never got a Smoking Gun
there's really nothing there so now
they're gonna have to make a very uh
obscure political argument uh I think if
Trump you're totally right if he fled
the country he couldn't be president it
obviously works I think part of it is
sort of gambling with them they really
want the perp walk they want an image of
him in handcuffs they want that to be
all you see for a long time uh and so
again for me all of this comes back to
timing right they could do it right now
but he's gaining every time they indict
him he he jumps in the polls so if they
released a picture from in handcuffs
who's to say this wouldn't actually
bolster his supporters it would help
exactly that's why they won't remand
them that's my point if they genuinely
thought Trump tried to overthrow this
country and led an Insurrection against
uh an official proceeding they'd be like
lock him up and throw away the key there
are people still in jail right now
without charge or trial for having
trespassed at the Capitol and you mean
to tell me that they're like Trump you
are free to go but we think you're the
one who orchestrated all of it nah yeah
think about it they don't believe it at
all think about the Q Anon Shaman right
Jacob chansley like think about we all
saw that video when when Tucker aired it
after McCarthy gave him all the film
from January 6th like you can make an
argument that he shouldn't have been in
the capital like that's fine but
obviously not violent right he was just
kind of Meandering around in there and
he was kept in in pre-trial detention
and then in prison for how long because
he was considered to be he was
considered to be it was the same charge
that one of the same charges that Trump
is obstruction of an official government
proceeding yeah and he I mean come on I
mean the same thing with like the proud
boy conspiracy trial it's crazy I will
say because you brought it up uh you
know we felt like the January 6 you know
imprisonment was sort of a sense of
President and it makes me wonder is
there a fear among uh left-leaning and
Democrat left-leaning lawmakers and
Democrats that eventually Republicans
will go after maybe Hillary Clinton or
someone else and then if they put Trump
in jail right now then they are setting
the president their leaders will have to
go in jail at the same point during the
trial uh maybe this is a sign that
they're actually scared
maybe I don't think they have anything
to worry about Democrats going to jail
and Republicans are in power
unfortunately I agree I agree
Republicans are going to send strongly
worded letters and then yeah it's just
the most pathetic pathetic thing
imaginable the the the the
the indictment against Donald Trump Lays
uh lays forth this this idea that you
can indict someone for defrauding this
country over elections
so where is where are any of the
Republican DA's anywhere in this country
to indict Hillary Clinton
for for acid washing or servers well I
mean she was she she's publicly stated
over and over again that Trump was
illegitimate and she was doing it to try
and you know steal power and all of
these things she was call accusing Trump
of being a Russian during the election
oh all right all right you know 2015 the
the all of the stuff that they started
pulling out against Donald Trump
accusing of working with Russians and
being a Russian asset and all this stuff
that was that was before Trump won yeah
what the statute of limitations on that
I can't imagine it's it's only a couple
years got to be at least 10 right it's
felony maybe there's no statute where's
any Republican to be like okay we're
filing charges but the jurisdiction
touches everything it's legal to say
that you think uh an election was
fraudulent if you truly not according to
the indictment but only again the
indictment's basically saying that
Trump's opinion even though he genuinely
believed it no no no no the indictment
says that Trump stated things that he
knew were false therefore it's illegal
it's pretty obvious to everyone that
Trump believed what he was saying sure
and let's make the same argument that
Hillary Clinton knew she was lying the
same as they say about Trump and go
arrest her own Republicans are pathetic
spineless whiny losers you can't prove
if they knew it or not there's no way of
course that's actually that's actually
one of the biggest flaws I think besides
the attack on the First Amendment that's
one of the biggest legal flaws is this
the the bar for the intent in these
different statutes is so high I I mean
it's it's arguably unconstitutional but
it would be next to impossible to prove
if you had unbiased jurors which I I
suppose there's a huge caveat in this
case because it's going to be in
Washington DC so not unless Trump gets
in West Virginia which I would
personally love there's no way that's
gonna happen the best thing of all time
he for sure I mean I don't know but he
really seems to believe like that
election was fraudulent he he's very
straightforward about it he's been the
entire time I don't understand why they
would assume that he's lying it makes
sense they're not assuming he's lying
they are lying they're purporting that
he's lying I suppose they they know
Trump really believes it but they're
lying and so the issue is
why is it that Vivek ramaswamy is filing
his lawsuits against the doj for
information pertaining to the
communications between Biden and Garland
as per this uh this indictment why is it
Vivek he's not even a politician and
he's more effective than whatever
Republican I'll give Matt Gates a pass
he's doing a lot of really great stuff
he's always on top of stuff but vivek's
just a candidate and he's like I'm gonna
file a lawsuit can we get a single
member of Congress to do something no
they're too busy holding hearings so
they can get viral Twitter Clips Tim
yeah that's about much more important
that's that's it do you spend much time
over there at congress not if I can help
it
check out this tweet from end wokeness
Trump now faces three indictments 78
charges 641 years in prison and we have
this uh this is this is great look at
this corruptly obstructing an official
proceeding one count conspiracy to
obstruct an official proceeding one
count 32 counts of retention of National
Defense information 34 counts of
falsifying business records and then you
got scheme to conceal lying to the US
government
641 years in prison is what they're
trying to throw at this guy that seems
reasonable yeah he definitely can serve
that time we're definitely not over
sentences then he'd be as old as Biden
when he got out that's true so how do
you think uh MSNBC is is handling this
they think it's reasonable take a look
at this clip from uh MSNBC and I would
appreciate it if you all would would
listen one day our children's children
will read American history and can you
imagine our reading the James Madison or
Thomas Jefferson tried to overthrow the
government so they could stay in power
that's what we're looking at we're
looking at American history could you
imagine if Thomas Jefferson tried to
overthrow the government I am shocked
everyone knows Thomas Jefferson stood
violently valiantly before the the
people of this great continent and said
all God Save the King all hail the king
we love the crown Britain forever that's
that's exactly the story of the founding
fathers but I just want to add I love
first of all how he's he's so he I'm
sorry man
he's talking about the founding fathers
quite literally over through the
government
and uh yeah but more importantly he's
comparing Donald Trump to the founding
fathers who overthrew a tyrant
for the people and established this
great nation they succeeded
it's kind of a weird perspective it's
like
you're set you're comparing Trump to the
founding fathers right there it's kind
of like okay well that's like a weird
thing to do because people like them and
then being like to overthrow the
government I'm like yeah they succeeded
at doing that so he's obviously his
defense he's talking about if they'd in
by you know 1811 Thomas Jefferson was
still 1806 or whatever he was still
refusing to let go of power and was like
we are gonna mean we are going to be the
new monarchy
um and so he's referring to that
absolutely not that's what Napoleon
absolutely he's talking about
fabricating context to defend someone if
you think that Al Sharpton doesn't know
that Thomas Jefferson was involved in
the American Revolution
is not an actual uh effective thought
leader he is the equivalent of a
political ambulance Chaser right he
shows up to do a couple hits to
fundraise and to make himself feel good
he's not a reliable source for anything
so the fact that this is who they're
triaging with should tell you that he
has no idea what he's talking about and
they are grasping a trust and I'm not
saying he did not know they they were
involved in Revolution I'm taking his
statement as it is I'm I'm establishing
no alternative context like you are
doing The Man compared Donald Trump to
founding fathers who overthrew the
government succeeded to to remove a
tyrant
comparison wrote the document that said
this is why we are overthrowing you this
is why we're Justified this is why we
have no other recourse we are now in
charge we're severing the political
bonds the Declaration of Independence
with them literally saying you have no
Authority anymore we're in charge now
well I'm still Manning his argument for
now it's funny we can laugh at the guy
and be like dumb idiot you didn't know
but like obviously he's talking about if
Thomas Jefferson had overthrown the
American government that makes no sense
there's no context in what he said to
assume he's talking about 1811 or
anything after why would you think he's
talking about King George that Thomas
Jefferson didn't overthrow King George
invoke the founding fathers the obvious
example is yes they overthrew a
government they were through the British
government but they didn't overthrow our
government
at the time at the time before they
overthrew it it wasn't not to mention
the critical race Theory argument is
that the founding fathers were wealthy
white slave owners who didn't want to
pay taxes so in order to maintain their
status and power over through the
government that like the point is it is
a stupid thing to say I agree with that
but I stand by you know I can't expect
anything better what's funny is MSNBC
did they even did they push back on this
at all or were they just like oh no
they're like Reverend Al sharp and thank
you for blessing us with your presence
here today uh we're so grateful I just
want to phrase it can you imagine like
let me get my crystal ball yes I can
imagine it would be first a declaration
and then a revolution and then a free
country the greatest the world has ever
known I can't actually imagine to be
fair it was a revolution then a
declaration in in the French Revolution
went haywire they started a revolution
it looked pretty good and then they
wouldn't let go of the power ropesphere
went insane completely egomaniacal and
then they started killing each other and
then Napoleon sees them but you know why
that is to be fair upstair was always
insane in the beginning he was really
lovable he was like a brilliant order he
was a lawyer everyone liked him he was
the most level-headed of all of them and
then something that happened I learned
an important lesson from Occupy Wall
Street because I knew some of these far
leftists and uh you know they fought for
free speech in 2011 and then when it
came to the Free Speech arguments in
2018 and 19 I asked I asked these guys
like this one guy I knew I was like how
could you be for free speech back then
and also in your opinion changed and he
laughed and said because you're too
stupid you didn't realize we were using
you we hate liberals when when you
defended our speech it empowered us and
now we want to take yours away from you
because we want power and I was like oh
it makes sense also you know what we
were talking about just before we went
on air we were talking about
libertarianism versus a more ordered
Liberty like a recognition of moral
order that's the biggest difference
between the French Revolution and the
American Revolution the American
Revolution was based I know this is
really historically nerdy was based on
this idea that there was some
fundamental objective truth that we
didn't just determine as as populism
right and the French Revolution chose
libertarianism instead so we ordered our
constitution on original Justice which
is like judeo-christian values in the
French Revolution didn't they ordered it
as Freedom as the ultimate end whereas
we viewed Freedom as the means of
something greater and the the I think
the one of the big differences a
catalyst and one of the principal
catalysts for the French Revolution was
economics
people were starving there was famine
and so you had all these French people
being like don't know don't care I'm
angry and that just led to beheadings
and other chaos whereas in the United
States it was consistent oppressive
actions by the crown and things like no
representation in government and the the
founding fathers and many of the state
leaders would repeatedly petition the
crown for things that made more sense on
our behalf and they would just say no
screw off over and over again so the
revolutionary period was actually about
20 years long and the Declaration of
Independence was way later on in that
whole period that's an interesting point
about the secularism of the French
Revolution it's interesting I haven't
really thought much about it but that
the American Revolution was like I don't
know if it's a Christian Revolution they
put God in in a lot of writings than the
the French Revolution is all about like
do away with the old God create a new
religion create a new calendar you know
we don't want to adhere to these oldies
I saw an interesting video where uh some
conservative dude was doing one of those
gotcha videos of stupid people in Times
Square and he asked what year did
America gain its independence and I
thought that question was really really
funny because even he did not know the
answer
because what what year was it anybody
have a guess
81 1781 are you talking about
technically because I mean if you want
to be real philosophical about this you
could argue that in some ways where it's
a continuous battle that's ongoing
forever 2023 be uh yeah I mean that's
kind of like a lame answer I actually
don't know the year are you talking
about like when the Constitution
Revolution ended the surrender of
Cornwallis
was that 81 did they fight yeah 81 81 at
Yorktown so that was uh
eight uh
oh wait that's the wrong one
uh 1781
so they announced it in 76. so you can
make the argument result we had our
independence in 1776 but I disagree uh
declaring it didn't change the fact the
crown asserted their Right and started
shooting at Americans to and actually
controlled a bunch of cities and
occupied places so we did not have it it
wasn't until Cornwallis surrendered that
we actually gained it so 1781 but I
think it's funny because they're like
what year was it and supposed to be 1776
it's like No actually that's when you
know they started sending the troops
right granted they were already sending
in the troops to be fair and that's kind
of a catalyst for it but uh yeah you
know I think I think what happened right
after is what's interesting because we
didn't have the Constitution for a while
after right we had instead with the
Articles of Confederation and that was
structured on more of a Libertarian
basis and it resulted in chaos and they
realized that we couldn't order a
society along those lines so we had to
we had to use the Constitution to
reorder it along James Madison's
viewpoints which were more ordered
Liberty I think there is something you
said for the question of you know people
think it's 1776 because they think when
you declared that you were independent
you had Independence because you have oh
well you claimed it you claimed it
you're aware that you want these things
but I think it is important to
underscore that you actually had to
fight for it you have to you have to
keep this going right you can seed
grounded a republic if you can keep it
yeah to be fair I was even wrong about
that the American Revolution officially
ended September 3rd 1783 with the
signing of the Treaty of Paris
Cornwallis is surrendered in 81 ended
any chance of the British actually being
able to win a war and so from that point
on there was still conflict and
occupation but then the treaty was
signed in 1783. that's crazy right yeah
like the American Revolution took place
over 20 some odd years you could have
been born a couple years after the start
of this period and then fought in the
War you know like your whole life was
hearing about all this revolutionary
stuff I mean that's true of anyone who
deployed to Afghanistan right I knew
people who were in kindergarten after
some people were born after 9 11 and
ended up serving in Afghanistan so these
things yeah that's trippy it is trippy
right yeah that makes me so mad the
Afghanistan stuff because I I have been
thinking a lot about the draft we talked
about the draft a few days ago and how
there was call people were talking about
it and it's like the military numbers
aren't doing very well
because they sent us into that occupying
war in the Middle East in Afghanistan
and then Iraq and Libya we conquered
Iraq and then we conquered Libya and
people are getting pissed off that
Russia wants to conquer a trade Port
right on its border like you
kidding me we took Libya we're in
control of Libya right now we own Libya
like this is the grossest and I
mean we need to inspire our military
that's what bothers me is that the
demoralization in the military I don't
think we own Libya
yeah and now there's a slave trade
instead of osprey Global did we set up
Sydney blumenthal's Osprey Global
Solutions there for Libya for a while
has been ruled by like random try
warring tribes since the fall of Gaddafi
yeah it's basically an American puppet
state my problem wasn't that we went
into Afghanistan I think that was
perfectly morally Justified after we had
been attacked on 9 11 my problem was how
they handled it like you go into a war
you have
um terms of Engagement that allow our
fighting men and women to win and you
actually have a plan for victory and you
have an objective that is Victory like
you get in you do your thing you get out
like don't drag it on forever there was
there was no reason to go into
Afghanistan
if the argument is that we should have
gone to Afghanistan because some of the
911 hijackers were Afghani it's like
what about the Taliban yeah but what
about Egypt or Pakistan or Saudi Arabia
I mean they're all Saudi Arabia got sued
I think over 9 11. but I'm not going to
get in the whole uh history of that
because there's too many gaps in my
knowledge but it wasn't like it was just
the Taliban that did it Osama Bin Laden
was hiding in Pakistan there was uh
funding coming from various sources in
various Middle Eastern countries some of
the hijackers were Egyptian we didn't go
and invade those countries I don't
disagree with that I think that that
Taliban was giving safe passage to Osama
Bin Laden so you you can go back and
make that argument I'm not especially
against Saudi Arabia I think that they
were certainly not held accountable
because they were a territorial Ally if
you will I think part but I do think 15
were citizens of Saudi Arabia yeah two
were from the Emirates one was from
Egypt and one was from Lebanon most of
them were from Saudi Arabia and we're
just like nah that's cool sad he's like
we're all right with you yeah I think
part of the problem is that war that we
pretended was in a war but obviously was
a war never ended right now I can tell
you people born after it deployed to
Afghanistan but then the Biden
Administration said we want to pull out
on September 11th to have some symbolic
win for our Administration we also how
that went like there is something
fundamentally wrong and I think to your
point uh you know
I have family members and I know people
who are part of the military and there
is an energy of discouragement but also
I don't think our culture knows totally
how to uh handle our military right I
mean I think a lot of us are anti-war
and I think that's probably good on the
other hand where do you put in people
who go into military service for
honorable reasons how do you reconcile
both things at once I'd like to build
solar-powered water condensation all
over the planet like if we could have
peacekeeping missions with our troops
and our military and actually I feel
like these conditions is like this is
actually something else we call it
peacekeeping business
Vietnam you know this is cool advice
what they do is they build these there's
a bunch of different ways you can do it
but they have these big white
plastic or something you know Carbon
structures that are flat up top and then
slowly as they get lower become rounded
and funneled and what happens is the
condensation sticks to it and the water
pours down and it fills up fresh water
by the morning you can actually have
them go underground so the air goes in
goes down underground and cools way down
underground and then you can have like
solar panels that are like heating
panels or cooling panels underground
that are connected to the solar up top
so it super cools the the gas
underground we got a lot of work that's
cool stuff the the reason I I like to
elaborate on the DS because they're
really awesome stuff we could be doing
but instead we just keep we just seem to
be blowing people up all over all over
the world that's what our money is good
for gender studies in Pakistan LK 99
that's room temperature superconductor
did you guys hear about that it's going
to change the entire Computing industry
Computing industry bro you have no idea
dude I have no idea it's like I'm that's
why no one's standing on the president I
love science I have to say I feel like I
come on this show and you guys teach me
so much so superconductors where you can
pass a lot of electricity through
without losing it uh you need to be they
need to be really cold but these can be
done at near room temperature apparently
proposed ambulance the claim is and
they're being reproduced superconductors
zero resistance transfer of electricity
we lose energy as it's transferred
around uh there's heat losses a bunch of
loss with the superconductor you don't
have that there's a lot of things you
can do they do super super conductor
levitation they'd be able to do like
maglev trains on the cheap it would
completely change Computing it would
completely change batteries it would uh
uh what people are claiming is that it
will make the world like a Sci-Fi
reality like this is a major
breakthrough on par with the the
discovery of the charged electromagnetic
spectrum yeah and because such
nobody believes it and they're waiting
for replication because room temperature
superconductors is going to like
yeah it's gonna be like sci-fi I heard
that they're they're replicating it now
and this was like deep fakes and with
obviously the internet all these weird
Technologies of like I'm really gonna be
able to imagine something and then see
it like with the neural net I I we're
entering like another time I think
that's the craziest things these these
uh Revolutions in Technologies
evolutions of technology I should say
are happening faster than ever before so
my thought is that we're just you we're
going to evolve into another species but
what do you think Liz like did you get a
brain chip no not right away never Elon
said that he would get one well I hope
he has a great time no thank you if most
people will get it if I see like
hundreds of thousands of young people in
high school getting it and just like
blowing test scores out of the water
learning much as languages becoming
really good at Athletics I would
consider it but I would rather have
something non-invasive like a helmet or
something like so you like the augmented
reality glasses I like you know anybody
who doesn't have a cell phone yeah
how many people do you know don't have
cell phones like five because I know
people who live off the grid right I
don't know anybody that doesn't have a
cell phone after like older than High
School our cell phones CIA tracking
devices oh certainly all your
information is tracked by any
intelligence agency around the world who
wants it so
conservatives know full well the Deep
state is tracking literally everything
they do every website they go to every
picture they look at every naughty thing
they do on the internet and they don't
care and they would then say well I'm
not getting the brain chip and it's like
oh please dude 10 years you'll all be
chipped here's here's where I think it's
different because when Apple what's
Apple's thing that's coming out that
augmented reality goggles that he just
announced a couple months ago there was
an engineer that worked on that who did
a thread on Twitter right after it was
announced who said I worked on part of
this as it was going I don't work there
anymore a lot of it's under NDA and he
was bragging he was proud of having
worked on it he was he was talking about
how what they wanted to teach it to do
was anticipate what you want so that you
could all so they could offer you things
as you're going and I thought well that
doesn't sound cool to me that sounds
like the ability to manipulate because
if you get used to them anticipating
then they could plant ideas that are
just like that could control your
movements I think that's very different
than a cell phone because you're not
it's not integrated into your
Consciousness even like I have myself in
my hand all the time obviously like
we're all obsessed with it but it's not
part of my decision-making process
because it hasn't been like
it hasn't been merged with my
Consciousness like that's really funny
to go without your cell phone yeah so
the one fair point I'll make is there's
a difference between holding something
in your hand and and having a surgery
right Molly people don't want to do
surgery but cell phones
changed everything before we had the
iPhone if you wanted to go on the
internet it was you'd go out and hang
out with your friends then be like I
when you get home I'll see what's
happening online then you'd go out and
hang out with your friends then come
home once I thought the iPhone came out
and people had this was like the the
expansion the explosion into 24 7 web
now you were on Facebook non-stop all
day every day a dramatic difference yeah
I don't disagree with that so our
conscious are our our Consciousness has
merged with the internet at this point
your phone is always with you and now
look I'm wearing a smart watch that
vibrates when someone tweets at me I
think the weird thing is it doesn't
actually do that because I blocked that
but like I get text messages your watch
is just like constantly going off right
no I think part of it is you'll start to
see a separation of societies right like
you asked me who do I know who doesn't
have cell phones and like they are all
off the grid mountain people who chose
to live that way and know they're going
without some Modern conveniences for
that reason I think I mean like you're a
young parent there will be parents who
opt to give their kid uh an Instagram
profile and an iPad really early on and
then there will be parents who say I'm
gonna hold out for as long as I possibly
can I think you will see a clear
difference in these things and maybe
we'll have data to say like hey these
people are benefiting here's here's
what's happening because that because
again technology is moving so quickly
we're able to track things better than
ever before on the other hand I think
culturally will just split apart people
have like the mountain people and the
tech people you mentioned before the
show like shared morality how it's such
an important part of a cohesive
government for instance the United
States government had like a shared kind
of a almost an authoritarian morality to
it but so I see this technology in this
augmented reality brainship lifestyle is
like a a fast track to a shared morality
they can tell us what we think or they
can make us believe a certain thing and
it could be good could be bad but like
do you think that it's even possible to
get humans to come together and begin to
share numerality without using like this
this mind meld Tech this internet I mean
I'm first of all I didn't say the word
authoritarian when it came to me that
was me that was you
I I wouldn't I just don't think it's an
accurate word to describe what I'm
talking about so
um
I think that cell phones have connected
us in a way like I'm grateful for my
cell phone I also see like the problems
that it has wrought like I actually
think the point that Tim was making is a
good is a good argument for my point
like Tick Tock has changed the minds and
I don't mean like change the thought
like change the ideological Minds like
it has changed the brains of gen Z and
not in a good way it should be an
argument people pushing further away
from augmented reality because already
just with disattached phones we've
wrecked a generation with that
um I think in your point is a point that
I make a lot that indoctrination is not
inherently immoral it's what's being
indoctrinated that determines whether
it's good or bad right like our
education system right now indoctrinates
children in like anti-American
anti-christian pro-marxist values and
that's wrong but it's not because this
school is being used for indoctrination
indoctrination is morally neutral we
actually should be using the education
system for indoctrination we should just
be indoctrinating children in what's
good and right and true we should be
indoctrinating them in American Civic
values and in Christian virtues even if
they're not practicing religious people
our nation is built like our entire
legal structure is built on the on on
judeo-christian values right you can't
murder someone why because that person's
made in the image and likeness of God
like that's the only thing that sets us
apart from animals so I think we should
be using venues that we have for
indoctrination we just have to be
smarter than the left and when's the
last time that you can point to
a conservative a republican politician
an institution that's actually
controlled by the right the rights
stopped fighting for those like 50 years
ago so it's just controlled by the left
so yeah they're forming the minds and
the ideologies of all these young people
it's terrible but it is changing with
the Bud Light for instance the new the
news that just came out they lost 400
million dollars or whatever there's a
big cultural shift sound of Freedom
obviously we'll get into that but I do
want to jump to this story because we
got big pressing news this is a clip
that was released by the national pulse
it is a leaked clip from Tucker
Carlson's show where the Capitol Police
Chief said that it was a that it could
be January 6 may have been a cover-up
let me play this clip for you I'll just
give you guys a warning it's a little
choppy for some reason but uh
nonetheless it's very important so let
me play this rational and not give a
number statement obviously but the facts
that you're describing are shocking
another state reason why I've had a lot
of people ask me you know why did you
write this book I tried to do what I can
to get the truth out yes you know they
didn't want me to testify in uh in
February 20th February 23rd at the
Senate hearing they don't want people
actually had to go in and talk to a
friend of mine on one of the oversight
committees to say I will come there in
person I want to be there I want to
testify so I'm glad you think I'm
reserved I'm you know to be honest with
you I'm a little pissed off
um because it doesn't have to happen if
if people were reporting intelligence
correctly if I was allowed to do my job
as the chief I got a significant
experience if I was allowed to do my job
as a chief we wouldn't be here today
this didn't happen then see how about
your land based in public and it's all
you know everything appears to be a
cover-up like I said I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but when you look at
the information intelligence that it had
military had uh it's all watered down I
mean I can intelligence support National
Guard in advance I'm denied National
Guard while we're under attack for 71
minutes you're in a fight yeah a fight
for a couple of minutes yeah one minute
I was gonna say 60 seconds three minutes
let me tell you it wears you out my
officers were fighting for 80 minutes
before the the protesters wait can I say
so you describe this as a failure to get
the intelligence to the people who
needed it but it sounds like worse than
it sounds like they were hiding so
intelligence and that's what I'm getting
at is
that actually did something to happen
and kind of wanted something to happen
it doesn't it's not a far stretch to
begin I don't know what the other
explanation is
you know it's it's sad when you start
putting everything together and thinking
about the way this played out uh it gets
for concerning what was their end goal
you look at you look at what's happening
was that their end goal I don't know
well I mean there's no question that
what happened on January 6th has has
really helped the Democratic party it's
bravely politicized the US Military
and the intelligence agencies and the
FBI and those are all I think bad for
America and violations of
they're all good for the Democratic
party that's the fact like that so it's
very it's a very choppy clip
unfortunately but you can make out most
of what uh what matters and this is the
former police chief of the Capitol
Police saying someone could have wanted
this to happen it may have been a
cover-up and then you look at what's
going on now with the Trump indictments
and I think anybody any reasonable
person who's been watching everything
that's going down would agree
The Simple Solution is
they wanted January 6 to happen to
weaponize it because they needed some
way to stop Donald Trump because they
know they can't win an election
here we are yeah I mean I'm not a
conspiracy theorist I'm not I usually
believe that there's an explanation but
if you look at the facts of the case
what happened on January 6th and compare
that to what the charges against the
January 6 defendants were and then
contrast that with the due process
violations that these people faced and
then the political Capital the Democrats
have gained for all this I mean
it almost seems like he's stating the
obvious we're just desensitized to this
because we've been dealing with it for
two and a half years now
yeah so you know that's the point I was
making the other day people will ask
like how did a country get so bad you
know insert country the Soviet Union
Nazi Germany like how did it get so bad
took years took a decade took longer so
when something happens like Donald Trump
gets indicted here's what I think
I think they indicted him on the tax
stuff first because they know what
they're doing
if they came out and had died at Trump
on January 6 outright it would be a
shock to the system that would be bad
for them it would snap people to
attention so they do an indictment not
that big a deal it's like a tax thing oh
who cares right then they do a
classified documents thing
okay well that's a little bit bigger wow
it's Federal but then ultimately it's
like yeah okay whatever now they do the
January 6th thing they're still not
remanding Trump into custody
the sheriff in uh in Fulton County said
that Trump will be perp walked and he
will get his mug shot he will receive no
special treatment
it's possible that the real romantic
custody will take place in Georgia
but they do it all in increments so that
you are desensitized to it every step of
the way but they want Trump to flee
because that's another January 6 type
thing
you get him to do it and then you can
blame him and make him look like the bad
guy again look he's still breaking the
law
yeah but imprisoning uh
whether whether they're good people or
bad people about history
we have tons of stories of people who
are imprisoned got out and then took
over and you technically could be the
president from jail from Exile let me
read you this timeline tell me if this
is a coincidence on March 16th the
oversight Committee in the House of
Representatives
revealed the Biden family payments that
we all know are criminally corrupt the
day after that on March 17th Hunter
Biden admitted that the laptop that we
all knew was his was in fact his
the day after that
president Trump announced that the
Manhattan D.A would indictment would
indict him which they did then on June
8th
the FBI
um the FBI an FBI document alleged that
Biden and Hunter you know were involved
in that bribery scam for five million
dollars the next day Trump was indicted
on the classified documents on July 26th
the hunter plea deal the one where he
was supposed to get immunity to any
other charges ever in the history of his
life that collapses the day after Trump
was indicted
July 31st Devin Archer testifies before
the house again and then the next day
Trump was indicted again yeah I don't
think so but the big the the the the the
Smoking Gun is
the third indictment which was
additional charges in the classified
document case because they had already
indicted him then the hunter Biden plea
deal thing happens then they're like uh
we're indicting Trump again for the same
thing it's like okay you they they
really need another indictment to cover
this one up I just don't understand why
there's no aliens too right any anything
to distract from it uh you know I want
to know why DC male mayor Muriel Bowser
has never had to explain why she said
yes we'll take National Guard but only
if they don't have any weapons right
like there were so many things that led
up to this that seemed strange to me
that Nancy Pelosi never asked for
additional security at the Capitol like
why are they not as accountable for what
happened as theoretically Trump or
anyone else like why are only certain
people being asked to account for the
decisions they made on that day that put
people in danger right like if you had
asked for proper security Nancy Pelosi
or mural Bowser then there would have
been something else the fact that you
didn't seem suspicious to me the fact
that no one is asking you to explain it
seems worse
yep I think they're counting on the fact
so think about in 2020 this doesn't have
anything to do with January 6 for a
second think about in 2020 when parents
were watching over their children's
shoulders on Zoom school and like they
were seeing critical race Theory like
your if your child's white they're
racist if your child's black they're
oppressed they were seeing the
transgender ideology and parents were
really shocked by that because a lot of
parents thought oh that's happening in
California that's happening in New York
but that's not happening like in our
neighborhood in our elementary school in
my child's classroom and they saw that
it was and this it was this huge mental
shift that you just saw sweep the
country all these parents that thought
they were Untouchable because they
weren't in this radical leftist hotbed
and then they realized that it was real
I think we're at that point with January
6 that for a long time people have been
afraid of being labeled as a conspiracy
theorist and because of that we've
forgotten that sometimes there are
conspiracies sometimes like what is a
conspiracy it's just a concerted
criminal act right that there are people
in power who are trying to do bad things
trying to violate our rights and I think
people people collectively are starting
to realize that January 6 is one of
those things that it wasn't just oh the
radical right-wingers who are claiming
that it was a that it was a false flag
or something like that they're like wait
a second this actually does seem like it
could be as bad as as some of us have
been saying the whole time yeah and
we're seeing a really big shift in
people's minds I think one of the first
time she was on this show murder Taylor
green pointed out that basically
everyone who's arrested during the 2020
Summer riots was let go and they never
faced any charges like we are singularly
focused on this one thing and there has
to be a reason for that right and I
think you know uh we saw it in the clip
someone gains from when they obsess
about January 6 and they try to turn it
into
something right there there is political
momentum and I think Tim talked about it
the other night you know if Trump had
treated uh the May attack at the church
in DC a little bit differently perhaps
The Narrative would have been slightly
differently uh I think that's one of the
things we have to credit uh left-wing
left wing activists with is that they
really know when to obsess and make loud
uh something that they are going to make
the lead story for the rest of the year
in this case it's generous X someone did
bring up an interesting points uh just
peachy in the Super Chat saying Tucker
did not use microphones like that on his
show and I just looked up quick set
images and sure enough yeah Tucker never
used uh microphones like this I don't
know what that means perhaps the the
video could have been faked or something
like that but I have no evidence that's
the case this would be a particularly
difficult video to deep fake because
it's extensive but considering how much
time it's been it's been January since
this book came out it's entirely
possible someone made an elaborate deep
fake can someone clip the original
interview when it was released slowly
change it it could be why the audio is
so so choppy or whatever but they were
trying to record it locally so that it
wasn't
I don't know leaked I think the simple
solution is just that this one-time
Tucker used these microphones but I have
no idea
don't know I just I just looked after
Carlson today and the images of everyone
he's had on every single image none of
them have that none of them have those
mics
so I'm like when did he ever use those
he didn't seem to have also unless it
was a different show unless it was uh
meant for an audio release and they just
happened to have filmed it
credit to his detail-oriented fans were
being like those aren't the mics
I feel like we should subtly change
things in this room and see if people
notice this this j6 man it makes me
think like if I was a Nazi Germany in
1933 or 1934 what would I be doing to
speak out against the Nazi party rise to
power would you be speaking out and how
would I be doing it because they didn't
have the citizens couldn't really grab a
microphone and go on the internet they
didn't have that kind of power yeah we
do but at the same time
people have uh can be drowned out
everybody has the microphone so everyone
is yelling over each other it is faster
but back then the the means of you
speaking out would be to make flyers and
posters or like to print a Zine or to
write something and then share it so you
got to stand out that with you saying
how people are all talking over each
other I guess that's for me why I'm
taking why I'm deciding to get into
shape because if I can make a really
good movie that people want to watch
then at least I'll be standing out and
people will be looking at my microphone
a little bit more than others well you
got to go where the money is right so
you got to go hang out in Malibu and
then hopefully you bump into you know
say Robert Downey Jr and then he's like
I like your style and then he puts you
in a movie and now you're famous yep now
you're famous and then you come out and
start talking about how the war in
Vietnam is bad and then one day on your
way to the hotel some guy jumps out and
shoots you oh okay thanks for laying the
uh that path in front of me which is why
you know what your options are I know
like do I rail against the military
powers of Earth until I die or do I just
try and make a great life with an
awesome family and go live on an island
I feel like there's both right like and
in this position you can talk out speak
about the things that you believe and
ask questions but I think change happens
at home and so there's a value in saying
like no matter what culture tells me I'm
going to live myself live my life you
know jointly hopefully with a partner
weird in a way that I feel like is
Honorable we're here for one reason I
think that's happening right now is
because of one thing
the founding fathers are the people who
said we are a moral and just people and
we Demand right we we have these rights
there inalienable and we must fight for
what is right for us and our families at
Great personal risk sacrificing their
blood and treasure and even in some
cases their families putting their
families at risk so that they could
fight for what was best for the entirety
of this nation
and then the mentality changed at some
point now the advice you're given is
just keep your head down and make money
ignore all of this and where we are now
is the average person today says I will
not risk myself my life my sacred blood
and treasure or my family they were
founding fathers whose children's uh
children were kidnapped whose families
were kidnapped and used as a leverage
for prisoner exchanges whose homes were
seized by the British by the crown who
cities that were entirely occupied and
they were forced to flee and today you
have people saying well I can't do that
because I have a family and I can't put
my family at risk it's like okay well
you're the opposite of the founding
fathers and perhaps I know easy for me
to say I don't have kids but I'll just
make that make sure you understand that
like the founding fathers were like even
if it means my family is is kidnapped
even if it means I die even if it means
I have nothing left to my name I stand
for what this what what must be and
today
it's inverted today it's I'm going to
lock my door hide and hope that it
passes over and it's that people are
doing well even the poor people are
doing well because of fascism because
we've bought off half the world of the
slave trade of half the world mining
these Rare Earth minerals and stuff for
us that's China yeah and in like the
Congo like the I don't know Cobalt mines
yeah geez it's disgusting so truly
fascism is is is dangerous in that it's
peaceful or can be very peaceful and
people have been Sedated by this but I
think it's really simple
the
the currents the the current way of life
that we have you know you can work for
an hour you know if you're like a uh the
average American salary you work a
couple hours and you're gonna go have a
Hibachi dinner with your family life is
easy so nobody wants to risk it
that's it let me go back to what Ian
said before though when you ask like
what am I supposed to do am I supposed
to have a microphone and have the
loudest voice am I supposed to hide away
with my family like what it how am I
supposed to fight back against this
because we are living in a unique point
of History like no we're not in Nazi
Germany like you can't replicate
anything exactly in history but there
we're at a dangerous point in our
country right where if this if if what
happens to Trump if he's criminalized
for free speech I mean you and I all of
us sitting here have to wonder okay
we've questioned the same things about
the 2020 election like are we next like
where does that like what's the limiting
principle on that like we all could be
on the line at the whim of a government
and I think this is one of the things
that the Republican party has lost sight
of this is one of my biggest critiques
with the Republican party is that there
is a just use of government right we
often conflate the idea of a limited
government with essentially no
government
and that's not what limited government
means limited government means a
government with enumerated powers that
is accountable to the people that is run
by the people it means that it's not a
dictator that has unlimited Authority it
doesn't mean that there's no just use of
the government and we as Republicans
have forgotten that we've we've we've
demonized anything to do with government
oh we don't government involved in that
we don't want to use government for this
we'd rather use family and free market
and all of that which is fine but we
also have to use the government to fight
back against these things we are not
just by ordering our families properly
going to be able to abolish the
administrative State we're not just by
sitting here behind microphones going to
be able to recapture our education
system there are things we have to use
the government for the just power of the
government for to recapture if we want
to re if we want to stop what the left
is doing to our society and if we want
to reclaim our society which was which
is supposed to be
um how the founders envisioned it right
so you and I should I mean even if we
are I know I'm more right-wing than you
are but we should be holding our
politicians accountable for that because
everything can't be done on an
individual basis I know this is what
conservatives have told us for the past
50 years that everything's just about
like us and our families and yeah that's
important but it's also using the
government and if we did that we'd be a
lot more successful I'd like to break up
Corp a lot of Corporations especially
the tech corporations they're just too
too monopolistic Google alphabet I love
you guys thanks for letting us stream
right now but come on the corporation is
way too big yeah good day Google Google
you got to break them up Mata you got to
break them up X you're cool what can
stay but what they did with Rockefeller
was they went into Standard Oil and
broke it up into like eight oil
companies the Rockefeller still a piece
of so he became even more wealthy and
influential after the breakup so we have
to watch that knowing that we can't
break up alphabet the same way that's
why I advocate for freeing their
software code because it's kind of like
you reduce their power you create
um an opportunity for the market to
compete if the code is available and
whoever has the best means of like terms
of service their their organizations
will win out but I think we need
government that because otherwise it's
gonna people would resort to sabotage
and I don't want to do that and I don't
want boycott's not enough I want to jump
to uh this story here we have this uh
clip from The Joe Rogan Experience
jackposovic says breaking Joe Rogan says
there was real fraud in the Kerry Lake
election the context Beyond this is a
story from the Daily Mail that finds 69
of Republicans believe that Biden uh his
win was illegitimate and that there was
widespread fraud but let's play this
clip first we got Patrick Bet David he
rocks and Joe Rogan also very great
how much election fraud do you think is
real here we go Joe you want to go to
election fraud yeah because I don't
think it's zero no it's not zero I think
we could all agree it's not no way it's
not zero and we know that these voting
machines can be with yeah and we
know that there's some irregularities uh
all that that carry Lake stuff in
Arizona that they're trying to dismiss
it doesn't look like that's invalid it
looks like there's real fraud there it
looks like there's some real Shenanigans
there at the very least there was voting
machines that weren't working properly
and it seems very suspicious that a lot
of them were in Republican areas there's
a lot of shenanigans there's a and I
think there's coordinated efforts to
make sure that certain people get
elected I don't know how far they go but
I know it's not zero he's right it is
not zero even Bill Barr said I wasn't
zero and that's the big question 69
percent of Republicans think there was
widespread fraud and Biden did not win
so uh there was a tweet it was Robbie
Starbuck put out a poll saying do you
think we're in a civil war and uh of
course you all know how I voted in that
poll but uh the overall overwhelming
majority of people said yes there were
four choices one was nowhere not and
then one was not yet but soon and that
was the second most voted position
so
here's the way I'll frame it
and I guess I've said this before it all
depends on where we go next
if Donald Trump is cleared of all
charges scotus says these charges are
are politicking and weaponizing the
justice department
Trump ends up winning Trump fires a
handful of people there are some reforms
it's a little a little tumultuous but
mostly we just we move past it no one
will ever talk about this as a civil war
or revolution or conflict they'll just
say you know there was a rough patch
if
it does escalate Beyond where we are now
not just today but probably January 6
probably 2016 will be considered the
second Civil War period
so 50 100 years from now if whatever is
happening now does break out into hot
conflict or totally totalitarianism or
something they'll write the conflict all
started in 2015 when when the Clinton
campaign falsely accused her Chief rival
of being a spy working for this right
for the Russian government and that
kicked off a chain of events which
resulted in impeachments Street battles
I think for sure it'll go back to
September 11th in The Patriot Act if if
it gets to like this is the time of
History where the United States ended it
will be remembered that that stupid bill
that let you put throw people in jail
with no cause but that's that that's
that's where it all began they won't say
that that's reductive they better when
you look at when we look at the the
Civil War period you could bring up
Bleeding Kansas but nobody considers
that the Civil War they consider it like
a component of pre-civil war and then if
you go back a couple decades to like um
what was I think the 1850s the the uh
what was it the catching slaves act or
whatever was a big Catalyst because
the bill was basically if slaves escaped
to the South to the north the north
would have to return the fugitives and
the north said you got it the bill was
passed and then the north said yeah
right we're not doing that so the South
was basically saying if the federal
government passes laws the north will
not adhere to what is the point of a
federal government it does nothing yep
we don't we don't go back and say it all
started here with the Fugitive Slave Act
no we say it was a component and people
will consider 911 as component but the
Civil War period I believe likely it
theoretically has a bunch of components
that lead into with like Occupy Wall
Street the Great Recession Afghanistan
and Iraq I mean demoralizing
destabilizing for the United States it
bankrupted our country the shift was
2015. I wouldn't Define a civil war
unless there was
when I say violence I guess I don't mean
just black lives matter violence or
antifa violence I would call it like if
there's conflict violence like a hot War
I would describe what we're in right now
as a cultural revolution which can be a
precursor to a hot War it can be a
precursor to a Civil War I voted in that
poll too and I voted not yet but soon
kind of like TBD dot dot dot cultural
revolution just means one side's not
fighting back that's exactly what's
happening yeah I mean because you know
whenever people say we're not in a civil
war because there's no hot conflict yet
I'll just say Aaron Danielson was shot
twice in the chest by a guy with a
Marxist tattoo with a BLM tattoo on his
neck yeah you're just not paying
attention to it there's been a ton of
violence the the BLM riots was a major
component of whatever this cultural
Civil War or or uh cultural revolution
is and yeah perhaps it is just a
revolution a communist I like that
cultural revolution that's what I think
is happening it's the same thing The Mao
did it's in the 50s it's the same thing
the whole dividing people into the left
and the right is that what Mao did to
create a cultural revolution so that
then you can pull the tail on one of the
dogs and they start chasing each other
and you're the crazy monkey that gets to
watch this is what the first half of my
book is about so like I when we see all
these crazy things like we just
described as like oh our culture's in
chaos or we're watching critical race
Theory and trans ideology being
indoctrinated into our kids and I'm like
okay why is this all happening at the
same time I mean I know that Republicans
don't fight back so maybe they just
thought it was an easy in but this seems
like a concern yeah yeah how did we get
here and it turns out as I looked into
this the answer to that is less of a why
and more of a who as I researched it I
found the people in the organizations
behind each of the attacks on all these
cultural institutions and they are
invariably marxists I mean even the
black lives matter movement that you
just mentioned I mean this is the
obvious one people are familiar with
this but the founders of the black lives
matter movement are openly marxists they
brag about being trained marxists you
see all these books I mean I see you
have genderqueer sitting here on the
table I mean the president of the
American Library Association is a
self-avowed Marxist these people are
actual Communists actual marxists and
they are using the destabilization of
our cultural institutions the Civil
institutions to get us to economic
destabilization so that they can topple
our government that is the definition of
a cultural revolution people are just
like whoa communist Marxist like it's
just Republican versus Democrat and if
you actually peel back the layers and
look at who's behind this it's not a
coincidence it's not chaos it's actual
Marxism
embraced Marxism
I think that they are ideological
marxists I think Marxism is is economic
we think of it economically when we
think of Karl Marx in The Communist
Manifesto we think of the uh working
class overthrowing the ruling class and
I think that that didn't really work it
didn't they didn't it never caught on to
become a global Revolution that they
wanted so it sort of died out but then
Antonio gromsey who was this uh Italian
Marxist founder of the Italian Communist
party or co-founder said well listen if
You observe the cultural revolutions
that were successful or these Marxist
revolutions they started culturally
first you overtake the Civil
institutions that the working class rely
on to destabilize society and then
they're willing to actually revolt
against the ruling class like the root
of all of this is economically they're
anti-capitalist and then many I mean
many if you if you analyze the Marxist
or the Communist ideology there's a
spiritual aspect of it too I mean the
United States is being targeted because
we are fundamentally a Christian Nation
built on Christian morals built on
judeo-christian morals and marxists
can't stand that can you the difference
between communism and Marxism
yeah it's essentially uh this the same
thing it's just a specific version of it
so communism is this false idea that
there can be Collective ownership of
everything that there is there's no
private property there's no one person
in charge it's just everybody owns
everything Marxism is uh the tool to
achieve that so Marxism pits one class
against another one saying that you know
the working class is oppressed they are
oppressed by the ruling class and in
order to achieve communism Marxism is
the Revolutionary tactic that's why it's
important I think to differentiate
between communism and the marxists that
are behind the cultural revolution here
because they are trying to destabilize
our society using that tactic to achieve
communism so there could be other
tactics to achieve communism than
Marxism including perhaps economic
um technocracy something where we're all
the same in a machine yeah technocracy
is so that's actually really interesting
I have a whole chapter in my book about
technocracy because technocracy is ruled
by the experts right like you you can't
you can't question fauci because fauci
is technocrat the root of technocracy
can be traced all the way back to French
socialists and Russian marxists who are
part of the Bolshevik Revolution there
was a a Russian Marxist who actually
described technocracy as a stepping
stone from capitalism to communism
because this was always the problem for
Communists and Marxist right people
aren't just going to be wake up one day
and be like oh cool we live in a free
Society yes I'd love to have communism
there has to be some frog in a pot of
boiling water moment in a culture where
people are slowly introduced you know
incrementally into communism technocracy
is a stepping stone for that that's why
we see it with the administrative State
we see it with fauci we see it with like
once you have kids you see this all the
time in like the pediatrician industry
you as a parent aren't allowed to
question anything anything from
breastfeeding to co-sleeping to vaccines
you have to defer to The Experts it's
everywhere and it's conditioning people
not to question not to dissent just to
obey which is the Communist way are
there historically uh examples of
Nations or people going towards that
communist route and then stopping and
saying Hell No realizing what's
happening and turning Civil Wars break
out has it ever been a peaceful
um regurgitation I I think it's probably
hard to cite examples because it
wouldn't be documented as a significant
moment if it just reversed itself and
never really went that way it's a good
question though because it's kind of a
chilling question if you think about it
if we can't sit here and name a cultural
revolution that headed or that was
trying to transform a free Society to a
communist Society it means that often it
wasn't stopped it either wasn't
significant enough or it wasn't stopped
because the examples that I can think of
are examples that took a relatively free
or relatively religious society and
turned it into oppression tyranny and
death there's the inverse there's Spain
the Communists and the and the and the
Republicans or the nationalists were
fighting and then it was the right that
won that one and same in in Germany the
Nazis destroying the Communists the
Nazis I mean one of the principal
components of the propaganda was to
fight communism
yeah the Bolsheviks yep
I I
believe there's a way to do it
peacefully with this technology but I
mean it's owned by the technocrats so I
don't know how that works I'd like to
say what I think online guys
sorry that goes back to what I was
saying before about like the augmented
reality that's why I I don't consider
myself a cynic I do consider myself a
skeptic because I don't trust these
people I don't trust the like AI people
always talk about AI being this like
sentient being this like this this thing
that can take over and think for itself
and I'm like no somebody is behind
writing the algorithms of all of those
things and that somebody is someone
whose ideology is very different than
ours who wants to use that to influence
the way that we or our children or
whoever think so that they can convince
those people to act in certain ways that
benefit their political ideology you
guys know you've all know a Harare yeah
he's with the uh World economic Force
yeah he does seem like that at first and
I want to give him the benefit of that
he's just on the Lex Friedman's podcast
Lexus hit him out of the park he just
had Benjamin Netanyahu on now he has
you've all on the show Good you know
he's Bridging the Gap he's willing to
speak to people that might be the most
outside the if you're not in the system
the most terrifying force on Earth is
this world economic Forum trying to put
people in pods and ship their brains and
read their thoughts pre-crime stuff like
that but you've all was talking about
intelligence and Consciousness and how
they're not really the same necessarily
we're building machines that are
intelligent but do they have
Consciousness and doesn't they don't
seem to
um
boy the question is how do you how do
you prove consciousness
that's yeah he didn't have an answer for
that either it's such a this is a great
Star Trek episode where uh data the
Android is effectively on trial because
they're trying to determine whether or
not he is a sentient being with rights
or a washing machine and so as we're
getting closer and closer to simulated
and simulated Consciousness where we
know we fabricated it but we can't
determine like I'll put this away with
chat GPT and where we're headed with
these video games already you've got
this mod on Skyrim where you can talk to
a video game character and it will talk
back using chat GPT we're a few years
away from I guess you can say passing
the Turing test is something long since
passed what we're getting to is you will
be presented with
a microphone and two speakers and you'll
be asked to ask a question and then you
tell us which one you think is real
which we think is fake already there's a
game called I think it's called bot or
not or something like that where you
what happens is
you get placed in a random chat with a
it's a green it's a black screen with
green text and then it'll say you start
you'll say something the other person
will say something back then after like
30 seconds it will say was it a human or
was it an AI you have to guess some
people will pretend to be Ai and try and
make it seem so you guess wrong
we're getting to the point where they're
going to ask you talk to this person and
talk to this person one of them is an AI
can you figure out which one and people
are not going to be able to do it what
they'll probably have to do is more than
just two because then you get a 50 50
thing they'll have to do like 10 and
they'll have one AI in there and then
they'll see what percentage people can
accurately guess which one's the AI but
once we get to that point where people
cannot and I think we're really close to
that already
then there's gonna be a question of what
is sentience at all because if you walk
up to a person on the street and you say
are you alive I say of course like do
you think of course I do uh do you
believe in God yes absolutely what are
these questions for this is ridiculous
who are you why are you asking these
questions what if we then did the same
thing but it was
an AI robot you walk up down the street
it looks just like a human because we've
synthesized them geez answers all the
questions perfectly how do you then
determine who is real and who is it AI
doesn't know it's an AI and it thinks
it's alive and real you've got to give
it rights I mean you've got to treat it
but the AI will be Network conversation
it's one AI not not when you see that
individual and you ask are you alive and
says yes you're actually looking at a
gigantic Mass not a single person just
looking at a computer this this is why I
always have to bring it back to religion
I know that so many Republicans and
conservatives and red pilled people
don't want to marry religion and
politics and I get that but you can't
have these existential we can't answer
these existential questions if you don't
have some baseline foundational beliefs
about reality right like sentience is
determined by if you're a human being if
you're made in the image and likeness of
God again doesn't mean you have to
worship God but if you can't answer that
Baseline question then you're gonna
you're gonna mistake a machine for a
real person and try to get a machine
right it's like really do think a robot
should have rights like no nobody thinks
that there was a case I covered sorry a
little bit uh last year it was in May of
22 where this um it's called the uh
non-human rights project they sued to
have this elephant named happy freed
from the zoo that she lives and they
said it's a one acre prison and happy
unlike other elephants has passed a
self-awareness test because happy had
they put an ax on Happy's forehead
so legally the elephant is regarded as a
thing right it's not doesn't have rights
because it's not a human
um it obviously deserves to be well
cared for and whatever else but it's not
entitled to rights to the same humans
are so they said it passed a
self-awareness test because there was a
white X on its forehead and it used its
trunk to touch it when looking in the
mirror so therefore it's aware of itself
and that therefore you know it's
entitled to rights over where it lives
and things like that and I found this
really interesting because obviously I
mean we should you're a Catholic we
could maybe make you talk about it but
uh sometimes people will write in and uh
when James is here he has to define the
differences between different types of
souls right this idea that something is
aware of itself that it has Intelligence
that is able to react to something is
that the same thing as Consciousness is
that the same thing as what humans
experience and whenever we talk about it
in terms of AI and robots I think of
this conversation in terms of Happy the
elephant AI Bots will get human rights
and will be regarded identically to any
other biologically born human for one
simple reason we cannot share
experiences therefore the default legal
position would have to be to protect the
innocent and if you can't determine
whether or not someone is an artificial
intelligence or an actual person then
they both must be treated as though
they're real people who are deserving of
rights which means there will be online
Bots that will be protected legally in
terms of the First Amendment there will
be if we ever get to the point of
human-like Androids that are
indistinguishable from humans you you
will not be able to violate the Fourth
Amendment rights of someone by scanning
their bodies or something to see if they
are I could imagine giving them
personhood I don't know about human
rights no like it's not about human it's
not about saying robots deserve human
rights it's about saying I cannot accuse
someone of being a robot and then you
say scanner on them because that
violates their privacy if they're coming
into a private establishment yes but not
in public so you will have ai Androids
walking around you want to live in a
society like that or do you think that
we should push back against that as a
society
I don't want to live in a society like
that but I don't think there's a I don't
think there's any way around it it's
impossible I think it's a Blade Runner
the idea of sentience and Consciousness
is really they're terms that have been
used to replace like the human person
right we don't want to think of the
human person as what the human person is
right we're constantly dehumanizing
people we're either treating each other
as objects we're thinking of ourselves
as just the top of the food chain we're
not thinking oh the human person is
different from animals because the human
person is an embodied Soul we are both
organic creatures and also Spiritual
Beings and if we allow like science who
I assume is like the ones coining
sentience and Consciousness to redefine
what makes us a person versus the
spiritual reality of what makes us a
person then we are going to descend in
that into that kind of chaos like it's
inevitable but we shouldn't allow that
to happen I mean I reject the idea of
sentience and Consciousness as a
barometer for or a standard for give
someone writes because think about an
infant like a zero to three month old
has neither of those two things think
about somebody who's mentally
the moment then when you can prove Souls
exist we can determine who gets rights
and who doesn't but that's the basis of
our country was built on the belief that
they do that's something like what I'm
presenting here is not a new idea it's
not a religion
it's like our constitution acknowledged
I mean even our declaration the problem
as Jefferson said we were by our creator
right down by our creator and so the
problem is if two people walk up to a
cop and they both look indistinguishable
from each other and they both pointed
the other and say they're a robot what's
the cop to do is he gonna pull out his
soul detection system to figure out
which ones worthy of Human Rights and
which one isn't or is or what if he says
you know what you're both robots and
then shoots them both uh oh one was a
human turns out the cop was the robot
the whole time what if the cop what if
the cop says I'm gonna use this scanning
device on you and the person says that's
a violation of my fourth amendment
rights you can't use it if you have
nothing to hide then why would you say
it doesn't matter Fourth Amendment no
you need a warrant you need probable
cause for a search like that you can't
just walk up to me and do it and the cop
says I don't care about your rights
because you might be a robot scan oops
it was a human well this is why I
wouldn't give them human rights but
personhood like corporations are people
legally so I can see why and you're
saying elephant they're giving elephants
personhood York ruled against it okay I
think in India they did something they
had dolphins and elephants as well so
weird so like if we're gonna get none of
the operations personhood then we can
get AI person I got a complaint about
this a legitimate complaint okay we were
hanging out in West Virginia in
Charleston and we had on West Street all
the time we're in uh Charleston not
Charlestown Charleston's like five hours
from here and we were checking out the
the capital complex and they had this
big fence put up it said no trespassing
and you and I saw I saw a I think it was
a pigeon flew right over the fence and
landed another side spot mocking me and
I looked at the pigeon and I said how
come the pigeon's allowed to go on the
other side and I'm and that's serious
question
I as a human being of soul and mind and
barred from stepping on the other side
of this fence for some arbitrary reason
but the animal is free from from the for
the consequences of law
we don't care at all that these animals
are coming and going as they please
pooping wherever they want
great intelligence comes great
responsibilities right this is called
pigeon philosophy but this is my actual
point
it's a serious question
animals actually have uh certain
exceptions in the law
to do things that humans cannot do
humans are more restricted than pigeons
pigeons could quite literally eat
whatever they want and crap wherever
they want and go wherever they want and
that's it in fact some migratory Birds
you can't even touch it's a federal
crime
I guess the animals that were really bad
we just eradicated them they we made it
that's what I'm saying ducks are
protected
not all but some ducks okay this is my
answer so the type of Freedom that
animals enjoy could be described as
absolute freedom right someone threatens
their family they kill them go wherever
you want it's like it's it's it's
Anarchy right the animal kingdom is
anarchy quick point if a bear or a
mountain lion protecting its family
kills a person they will hunt it down
and kill it
okay yeah so that that that you know but
if you're like a duck and someone goes
near your babies and then the duck let's
say I shouldn't say your deck but if a
dog if you go near Ducks babies and it
starts attacking you they're gonna yell
at you and get away from that dog's
babies
yeah which is kind of ridiculous I think
we're gonna agree I mean it's kind of
like that comparison that if you break
the egg of a bald eagle you're liable
under federal crime but you can abort a
human child and you're allowed to do
that yeah that's exactly it right there
if you step on a turtle egg on accident
you'll get in trouble but you can abort
a baby out right at any point in
Colorado yeah see that's what I'm saying
humans have less rights than animals
some animals like cows have less rights
than humans don't get me wrong we've got
less Freedom animals don't have any
rights but that's the thing that's my
point is it's not less Freedom it's
different Freedom no no no no right
different definition of freedom because
rights are not granted
like granted by our creator humans don't
Grant rights we have rights right
animals can travel around they can
defend themselves they can seek shelter
they can say whatever they want granted
it's limited to squawking and growling
they can do all of that they can defend
themselves if you start climbing up
towards a bird's nest and the bird
starts pecking your head that bird is
not going to be harmed in any way by
anyone in fact humans will yell at you
for having done it if you grab the egg
from a bird's nest and throw it your
neighbors will probably get really
really mad at you and complain about
what you did but you can quite literally
this is a hilarious thing
what do you think would happen if a
woman who was eight months pregnant in
Colorado was walking into an abortion
clinic and before she went in she just
smashed a bunch of duck eggs
people would say how dare you smash
those duck eggs why why are you harming
those baby ducks and then she goes away
and then and then she goes inside and
right so the reason I think and so all
of this is so funny it is true I mean
it's true it's funny because it's true
but it's also because humans aren't
governed by absolute freedom we have an
acknowledgment that we are supposed to
live within some sort of moral order so
perhaps smashing duck eggs for no reason
or shooting a ball of the eagle just to
make it a trophy or harming an animal or
or you know killing an endangered
species we as a society acknowledge that
that's an immoral thing which is why our
actions are governed by a government
that's supposed to be comprised of
ourselves
and so we're supposed to live in some
kind of order we're not supposed to live
in Anarchy the way that animals do how
do we create the moral structure
sociologically literally with this
technology in modern day how what do you
propose
you mean how do we Define morality yeah
well luckily I don't have to be the one
that answers that question in the sense
that I don't have to write that code we
don't have to decide that in a populist
manner I mean the way that our
government was already created was to be
governed by morality as defined by
original Edmund Burke called it original
Justice which is natural law so natural
law is your ability to reason as a human
being my ability to reason we know that
it's immoral to go out and be a serial
killer we know that not because it's not
because it's socialized into us but we
know that that's inherently wrong
um we we are able actually to discern
right from wrong without being taught
that's why the marxists try to
indoctrinate our children so young so
that they can twist our natural our
understanding of reason or our reason in
in being able to discern natural law so
our society should be based our laws and
our moral order should be based on
natural law again not forcing anyone to
worship any God they don't want to but
the laws of our society should be based
on the definition of right and wrong and
Justice and Liberty as already defined
by our creator what about like starving
family stealing food
is that you think that's punishable by
like they used to kill people for that
kind of thing but desperate times you
know but like what do you is that moral
or just for a starving family to steal
food well it seems a little hyperbolic
it seems like the exception to the rule
and not the rule if we have a society
that's based on moral order there should
be other recourse before before that's
necessary I mean no I don't think that
killing someone for stealing food is a
just punishment and theoretically a
moral society would have other people
who feel obligated to help those who are
like don't make the mistake of comparing
ancient law to Modern context stealing
food 2 000 years ago you would be
killing the person who stole the food
from food was harder to come by people
were more strained and someone who was
selling food like food was accounted for
so if you if you were like I'm starving
so I'm gonna steal from you it's like
you are sentencing my family to death
yeah that's actually a really good point
because now it's like well you're too
lazy to get a job or you wanted
something that was too expensive for you
or you're not behaving the way that
you're supposed to be behaving like our
society is abundant with resources
there's no reason that anyone should be
be stealing food now you can get help
you can I mean I'm a conservative and I
still believe in a limited government
welfare safety net for people who can't
help themselves right like we all do
we're all we all believe in and like
soup kitchens are typically run by
religious food banks or Community
organizations like we formed other ways
to help people in need it's not like you
you either starve or you steal exactly
we have other options here I think it's
two reductionist to say that like those
are the only options
like that subject
well the last part I was just going to
talk about intelligence sentience and
Consciousness again those three words
and how they form into the totalitarian
step towards communism but I it's a long
let's let's talk a bit about philosophy
and religion we do the members portion
because I do want to talk about a News
segment for our last time before super
chats we have this tweet from Matthew
Iglesias and he asked an interesting
question he says I'm a very
literal-minded person but I don't
understand the idea of a guy currently
losing the race for the GOP Presidential
nomination debating Democrat who isn't
running I want to pause real quick and
say just because the sentence may be
dropping in polls doesn't mean he
shouldn't be debating anybody no I mean
he's trying to win so he's going to do
this but it is an interesting question
of why Rhonda Santos who's in second uh
place is debating a guy who's not
running for office so we have the the
story here from Politico DeSantis agrees
to debate Gavin Newsom on Fox News the
California governor has been trying to
get his Florida Republican counterparts
to engage on Wednesday he got it
okay so serious question why do you guys
think these guys are in a debate like
what's the point well I think you
mentioned it before the show I mean I
think they are both trying to gain
attention I think that they both would
ultimately like to be the people who are
facing off on the ticket I think if they
had done this at the height of kovid
when they both had such different
strategies it would be a really
interesting conversation for now it just
seems like their establishments are
trying to Rally around them and make it
seem like they are really the people in
charge especially interesting because
Joe Biden is the incumbent yeah this
strikes me as like a measuring contest
they're going to whip it out and see who
has a bigger GDP
who states bigger yeah actually that's a
good point I think that's they're gonna
do California is gonna knew Something's
Gonna be back in California we did this
and Ron's gonna be like you got poop in
the streets everywhere I hope he does
say that yeah I really I think this
would have been so much more interesting
if this was done six months ago before
DeSantis announced that he was running
for president yeah because this is a
legitimate debate how California handled
kovid versus how Florida handled covet
if you could have two states that are
like case studies against each other it
would be great yeah and the American
people really want to know that and a
critique of Ron De Santa since he
launched his campaign is this is what he
should have launched his campaign on
instead of attacking Trump personally or
having a surrogates attack Trump he
should have just constantly been talking
about what they did during covet and
people could make the comparison for
themselves without feeling that he or
his people were attacking Trump so maybe
this is his attempt to reset his
campaign since it was kind of a slow
roll out to to use a kind word there so
Santa's I think is just so bitter that
Joe Biden is going to be the nominee for
2024 just can't believe it
I think newsom's going to be the
Democrats guy yeah this looks like this
is newsom's coming out party this is
like him announcing he's going to run
for president basically why would he be
debating a vice a presidential candidate
and I said this last night and I'll say
it again the best possible scenario for
Democrats is Joe Biden at a rally Newsom
is there as a surrogate just in support
health issue affects Joe Biden panicked
in front of a crowd and in front of
Television Newsome runs full speed to
render first aid Panic ensues Newsome
then does the Press rounds of the guy
what was it like what was going through
rolling up his sleeves taking the jacket
off losing his tie and then screaming
for help and then putting on every
single television network what was it
like when you when you saved the
president's life that is the best case
scenario Democrats could have to get
this guy in the race I would also like
to I think that is the best case
scenario it makes me wonder As We Know
Joe Biden famously spends most of his
weekends almost all of them in Delaware
where one could maybe potentially get
secret medical treatment I wonder if
there will be I'm just gonna say I don't
know I'm just typing uh it's just
hypothetical uh I wonder if sort of
along same lines we're gonna get an
announcement that tragically uh Joe
Biden has some sort of terminal illness
that won't allow him to continue so
though he wanted to we've got to have
someone else come forward and this will
place Newsome as the obvious Contender
it depends on how sneaky and capable you
think Democrats are because if Joe Biden
says I'm sick bro that's really damaging
for the Democrats as a brand they're
they're sickly leader and they were
forced to replace them Gavin news and
then then steps into The Fray as a
second tier Joe Biden nah it's not going
to fly Trump is winning in the polls and
even with the scenario described I do
not see a landslide possibility right
you'd think about going you go back in
time when the country is a bit more
cohesive a president having a heart
attack on stage and someone running out
and saving his life with CPR that guy's
gonna have an approval rating in the in
the 80s or 90s and he says something
like I may disagree we may be political
Rivals but we were all Americans and
they're going to be screaming even with
something like that Democrats would not
be able to muster Landslide level votes
because people are torn apart people
hate the Democrats but if the Democrat
route is Joe Biden is weak and Bows out
Trump wins I I don't think you're wrong
I'm just saying it's probably again
depending on what they're they're able
to Stage it's probably simpler if they
just say Joe Biden has to exit he's not
going to be around they're super simple
but failing yeah like lose face if they
did that I think Newsom I just don't
know what the odds are like I said we
gotta check the calendar see when
they're gonna appear on stage together
and all get prepared to watch they do if
they do
um I'm not saying it will happen I'm
just like
look if you were to ask me we talk about
January 6th that that video comes out
where the police chief is basically
saying someone may have wanted this
happen it's a cover-up January 6 was the
best thing for Democrats it's giving
them everything it's giving them the
Insurrection act to remove people from
office they got that guy Griffin I think
his name was removed from office they
they said oh he was an insurrectionist
now they're indicting Trump they're they
did the January 6 committees it may not
be as effective as they hope it is but
it is their weapon thinking in that
context I've said if Donald Trump did
not stop the riding on May 29th in DC
he'd still be president because the
narrative would be inverted
in that same context I'm thinking
forward what could the Democrats do that
would guarantee a victory or at least to
a certain degree rapidly accelerate
their possibility of winning and it's
Gavin Newsom on camera on every major
Network performing CPR and Joe Biden and
saving his life it also explains why he
was LeapFrog Kamal here there's one
exactly and how they get Joe Biden other
race and Gavin in as the front runner
there's one Democrat who doesn't want
Joe Biden to bow out one Jill no Joe
Biden this is a quote from Barack Obama
in November of 2020. this is what he
said if I could make an arrangement
where I had a stand-in or a front man or
front woman to be president and they had
an earpiece in and I was just in my
basement in my sweats looking through
the stuff and I could sort of deliver
the lines while someone was doing all
the talking and ceremony I'd be fine
with that and Giovanni was like I'm your
man don't even worry about it no they
were like Joe Biden you're the man
oh no way that he would let Barack Obama
control via an earpiece absolutely he
would Newsome is a lizard person I mean
that figuratively medium matters calmed
down he's going to be like tell me
whatever tell me tell me what to do
because he he's just a slimy guy who
wants power he didn't care I think
there's two different camps of Democrats
though there's like the Chicago the
corrupt Chicago people and then there's
the California people right like Nancy
Pelosi came from California politics
Schumer came from California politics
like
um these Newsome and Pelosi are like
indirectly related right am I totally
wrong are they I'm gonna double check
that I don't know I don't know I mean
not it wasn't Schumer it was
um Adam Schiff came from California not
Schumer Schumer's in New York yeah yeah
um there's like this this this
California breed of Democrats who are
very radical left and then there's the
Chicago breed and they're kind of in
competition with each other because they
both want to be the leaders of the
Democrats in Washington DC so I don't
think that he would listen to Barack
Obama the way that Biden would so like
the Clinton Obama Camp Biden all that is
that's like a unique kind of structure
within that system and then there's
other people like that's interesting
Newsome was his
uncle by marriage was Nancy Pelosi's
brother-in-law so they were at one point
very indirectly related I will say that
they do have a lot in common you know
they both uh didn't wear masks when they
instructed everyone else too yeah in
California they can do whatever they
want I will say I actually am super open
I I am critical of debates because I
feel like these big stage you know you
have six 12 candidates on where they
scream each other and try to get their
viral moments it's not effective we're
not learning anything about policy it's
it's whatever but I I think one-on-one
debates I mean you see this with culture
War can be really effective and having
Governors face off especially on issues
where their states in particular become
representations of cultural differences
that would be super cool like I would
love to see the governor of Washington
debate the governor of Idaho on the
abortion travel law right there are
things that could be good about this
format I'm just saying right now this is
obviously playing into the presidential
candidate as opposed to the welfare of
their states there are two factions in
this country
that we here at timcast are unable to
book and it is
prominent leftist personalities and the
DeSantis campaign
I had someone tell me that they don't
want to come on IRL uh someone who's for
to Santa say well you know irl's two
pro-trump so it's not even worth going
on but I feel like it is worth coming on
to at least talk about it but they're
it's so weird I feel like they're
walking into a hostile environment we
had we had Lance from the Surfs and vosh
come on this show you know we had uh uh
uh Emma from the majority report come on
the show but it's it's what would you
ask them if they came on the show we
would have any descended supporter on
the show the same as we're having you on
the show and we would talk about the
exact same things but they've explicitly
said they won't have people on the show
and so we're actually supposed to have a
big culture War uh show not this week
next week debating between two
supporters of DeSantis uh DeSantis
support on a trump supporter and the
defendant supporter just said he wants
to back out because he's now back in
Trump and we were trying to get someone
from the sentences campaign we can't do
it yeah because I think that's actually
what they won't I feel like you want in
particular but you know to have a
variety of opinions that's actually
better we I think you never really want
to be a part of the echo chamber and
that's why you need to have people from
both sides it's interesting that they
are it is choosing even though the
invitation is open it is it is funny
that we're it's easier for us to get
leftists than it is to get the Santa
supporters you got to say they'll do it
to be fair to people hey John cardillo
on the show right so it's not like we
don't get any of course and he and he
stated this case the weird part is I
can't tell the difference between
cardillo and anybody else like I don't
care the pilot I really don't mind the
politics you know I would love to debate
Marxism with the Marxist I want to know
more about it like tell me yeah I think
that's the thing you want to have more
information and especially like if you
had someone who was on the the Santa's
campaign here we could ask more specific
questions about what's going on and they
could answer them yeah I'm a manifest so
if we start manifesting they will come
on we might so what we're thinking for
the next uh tomorrow we have Alex Stein
and Modine coming on
are they going to fight right here at
this table I know but uh I don't even I
don't know let's see what happens to the
show but then the next week the question
was do we ask the former Trump former
descendants supporter now Trump
supporter to just bow out and we'll find
someone who's backing DeSantis or do we
actually just keep the booking as it is
and then hear the arguments as to why he
no longer does and why he did it's tough
because there's there are a few people
we could I could probably reach out to
John Cardell and ask him who wants to
come on and debate protestantis uh I
think Kurt schlitter might be a
descended supporter I'm not entirely
sure there's a handful that are that are
you know in the bag for uh uh in the
corner for DeSantis I don't know what do
you guys think should we
just keep it as it is and hear why this
guy no longer supports DeSantis or
should we try and get somebody else I
think cartel will be interesting just
because he was so gung-ho I wonder if he
still as gung-ho as he was in the past
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna say who it
is
yeah well I'll I'll I won't I won't say
who the person is who's no longer
backing to sandusk because that's their
private business to announce but Laura
Loomer will be coming on and then we are
looking for someone who was a disanta
supporter so I I feel like it would be
interesting to hear this person's
perspective of why they were for santis
and then change in terms of a debate
like to keep that Spirit of culture War
alive I do feel like you have to find
someone yeah from the DeSantis camp and
like well they won't do it well the
question is like I agree you've had a
lot of people on like maybe there are
stances people who have been on the show
before who would be willing to do it if
Johnson maybe I think it would be more
interesting for a debate if someone was
like already very committed to the
disaster scan committed to the Trump
Camp it's not going to be really that
same it's not going to be a debate if it
the other way the perspective of going
from one to the other is interesting
theoretically you could have both you
could have a different debate where it's
this this person who's gone from being
supportive of DeSantis moving to Trump
and and the opposite this is actually
why I think it's silly for people to get
into camp this early like you don't know
how a candidate's gonna behave you don't
know what's going to happen areas like
in March isn't it
yeah coming up
eight months away that's eight months
from now like when did DeSantis even
announce
like that's that's quick to be like
entirely committed to one candidate like
I'm gonna vote in the Republican primary
I don't know who I'm gonna vote for and
I'm not in like any rush to make this
decision like I want to let the whole
thing play out it's why I don't like
early voting it's like a lot of things
happen no one in my view is more
committed to Trump's campaign than Laura
Loomer true like 10 out of 10. there are
people who are fans of trump but like
Laura is and you're after yeah hunger
has been consistent for a long time I'm
going 100 miles an hour and I'd love to
have a show with one of Trump's most
Ardent supporters and one of the Santa's
most one of the sentences most Ardent
supporters but we cannot get this and
this is most Ardent supporters they
don't want to do it we can you got to
manifest that they want it just start
saying they want to come on I think we
should just comb back through who's been
on IRL and see like if they'd be willing
to come on because I think some of it is
I would at least personally like if
you're not aware of what the
environment's like feeling like you're
going into a place that like already
hates you I mean that takes a lot of
nerve the the
fortunate issue is that the people not
that we hate to Santa's supporters
that's not it the Santa supporters I'll
just keep this vague as I can
people we've had on the show before who
are now in the DeSantis Camp are barred
from coming on the show
that's it like you think it's a top-down
directive that I don't think I know the
DeSantis Camp has forbade people from
coming on the show this seems crazy like
it's crazy to me I feel like you would
want to have the ideas like have people
ask questions like I hate that that
makes me like very sad do you think it
would be hostile to a DeSantis campaign
surrogate if they were on the show no be
awesome we we had we had John
cardillo on the show and there was there
was there was some some issues so
awesome and that was recently that was a
couple weeks ago or like a month ago or
something yeah Vivek involved Donald
Trump and Rhonda Sanders have talks
that's what the Republican debate should
be it's just a a table around here
everyone three hours I mean you're
moderating well we are we are organizing
for the culture War uh some of the
presidential candidates to come on all
at the same time and and that'd be so
cool and so I think we've got a few who
have said yes already but uh I'm really
hoping Marion Williamson will come I'm a
big fan she's fantastic yeah so I won't
say too much about that because I was
like
you know talking to Lisa Reynold she
does the booking I was like if we get
more than three people we have to get an
auditorium and do like a big thing yeah
like but it would be cool if it was just
sitting on a table and everyone kind of
just like talking at each other would be
it's a better form yeah you know it's
like more it's like raw it's like real
there's no Echo yeah yeah it's not like
hello yeah big Auditorium I mean that's
cool but it would be it's it'll be
really great just have like Vivek like
if the fake was talking with Marion
Williamson it's going to be a polite
cordial conversation about these issues
yeah it would be a fantastic quote
unquote debate because they're going to
be professional and polite and have a
real conversation with each other in
front of people as opposed to this
current system that we've been doing
where it's like question for you and you
can respond you have one minute to
answer is here's the million dollar
question is if you had all the uh
Republican candidates sitting around the
table who would you sit next to each
other how would you sit them just right
here honestly I'd probably just tell
them to say whatever they wanted to sit
yeah it'd be interesting to see what I
picked themselves yeah yeah is that
would be like Donald would be like you
can sit at the head of the table Donald
because it's the chair we used the least
but he wouldn't know I mean you'd be
like no no if you're the people who
watch the show no this is like the the
normal chair that people sit in so yeah
but the American flag I know it I mean I
personally love this chair how do you
actually debate background how you
debate Trump and win is in this format
the stage format is Trump's Battlefield
he owns that he cut you off CNN Town
Hall yep he can cut you off he can mock
you they give him the opportunity for
for a button he'll cut you off but in a
situation like this he would play very
very well but it's a different you'd get
someone talking loudly and then they go
back and forth he'd listen a lot you'd
see the humanity in him which I think
like you'd have to tell him to wear his
golf outfits you know like golf hat and
his collared shirt like don't come in
here in like the power suit we're gonna
go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com click join us become a
member and you'll get access to our
uncensored members only portion of the
show we do those Monday through Thursday
at 10 pm and uh tonight we're going to
talk about moral philosophy and religion
because we do this periodically and I
think I always love an opportunity to do
so but I really want to talk about the
structure of government who we vote for
why and what we need in this country as
it pertains to ethics morals religious
and spiritual values so that'll be a
deep conversation and U.S members get to
call in so sign up today let's read I'm
not your buddy guy says the biggest
first reason why I believe 2020 was
genuine fraud is because a a month prior
to the election the Google trending
search was penalties for voter fraud and
B the response after 2020 I mean it was
like Anthony Weiner defending himself
and the Clinton Body Count absurd if
anything there needs to be a deep dive
into the Intel community and what they
do is I would not be surprised if
decades ago they tried to cheat
Communists from winning
I hear ya
I hear that uh well Vivek is filing
these doj uh foia requests to to figure
out what they were saying to each other
and pertain uh relating to the
indictments of Donald Trump that's
fantastic
all right voice of the people says of
course it was a cover-up remember
Pelosi's coup attempt why was her
daughter filming that day what did she
mean by she's waiting for that moment
why did she block the National Guard
interesting questions she did literally
say that I believe right she said
waiting for that moment or something
yeah there's this is a light context to
truly understand these specific phrases
you got to look into the deeper stories
about what they actually mean it's like
hard to just condense all those things
into talking points
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim Biden gets
into the farm so Newsome is the nominee
Trump is convicted and can't run so
DeSantis is the nominee that's why
they're debating it's all part of the
deep state uniparty plan
I'm not saying uh you know I I I I think
it's a possibility but it doesn't mean
that Newsome and DeSantis are in on it
it means that Newsome wants to run
he hasn't announced yet because Biden's
still in the way but I believe it's a
fair point the intelligence agencies
would love to have DeSantis versus uh
Newsome Biden is two weak probably can't
win DeSantis is going to get elected and
then he's going to compromise in the
same way Trump did we all said oh drain
the swamp to Santa says he's going to
start firing deep state right away he
probably will but he's gonna go to these
people and he's gonna say look we don't
want war we want to set some policies
we'll do our thing and then they'll say
yeah sure no problem and then it'll be
Trump all over again the only reason I
consider Trump for round two is because
he wants revenge DeSantis hasn't yet
experienced that so I'm not I think it
really comes down to
well I'll put it this way Trump is more
likely to fire people than desantises in
my opinion because he wants revenge and
then everyone says but you didn't do it
in the first place and I'm like yeah but
now he wants revenge like that's the key
factor here and then the issue with the
sanderson's campaign is mismanaged and
so I'm not super confident anymore but
you know we'll see we'll see
Gary G says Tim what kind of watches
that looks cool this is the uh what is
it Garmin Phoenix Pro so uh we were
hanging out with Luke when I was at
Tijuana and he had one of these I don't
know if he had this one specifically he
had a bigger one and it does a lot of
Health tracking stuff which is actually
pretty good and then he made fun of my
analog watch and I was like you know
what I'll get one of these it's actually
it's really cool because for uh Fitness
training first of all it's solar powered
so not the battery lasts like a month
that's crazy but uh it's got a
flashlight on it too look at this it's
got a light you see that that's crazy
yeah super crazy a little flashlight on
the watch but um just double tap it
turns on but it tracks in simple
language my uh um my exercise routine so
for instance I skated pretty heavily on
Monday
and then it showed me what degree of
recovery I'm at throughout the day and
the level like the level of intensity
I'm I should be
you know uh exercising at to maintain
maximum recovery and I got wiped out on
Monday skated for like two hours super
intense non-stop took a break on Tuesday
on Wednesday yesterday I was pretty
tired pretty sore but it said moderate
exercise capable and it made sense
because I was a little sore and then I
skated as hard as possible and it gave
me a warning this white screen popped up
and it was like you are over exerting
yourself your recovery time is being
extended human bow to us
well I just kept skating it can tell me
I can't but my point is it tracked all
of this data and is explaining to me uh
you know a lot of the basic data so I
like it it's just a smart watch this is
why I don't want to use it because it
tracks the data I don't get it so you
and Luke are both really like
libertarian outspoken about like no
world economic form We're not gonna be
good in your pod but like why do you
track your Biometrics because that's
sending it right to them I think that's
the hard thing because I there are times
that it's really interesting to know how
your body's responding massively
valuable data I agree right and like is
there a way to unhook it from it's being
sent to the AI well but listen
there's a laser on the back of this and
it's uh scanning like the blood moving
through my wrist it's how it tracks
everything your oxygen levels your heart
rate variability your heart rate heart
rate's the easiest one obviously
it's tracking data points we can't
perceive as humans there will come a
time and we're very very close to this
already where you'll buy the watch
you'll put it on and then after a week
it'll say we after analyzing your data
we have found that you have these you
know these uh markers and it'll be like
pre-diabetic it'll say potential cancer
at this age you know heart health issues
at this age it can see things in the
data that we can't notice but when
enough people use these Health trackers
pros and cons man I totally get it Mass
buying versus you know AI benefit
if everybody used this the the the
network would know okay all diabetics
have this level of X all cancer patients
have this level of X and then when you
put it on it'll be able to diagnose you
instantly you know the doctor it'll just
be like based on everything we know
about humans you have this problem and
you need this message if it's an honest
AI but if the code is proprietary I
could see it being like oh they watched
one of our commercials and it's making
them
you forgot about the part of the
algorithm that's like you're white so
you can go to the back of the line for
the medical care that you need
well I'm not so I'm I'm cool you know
are you gonna pull that one quarter
thing right now
when I need to absolutely me too except
all right all right let's read some more
we got Max Reddick he says you should
have Destiny back on to talk about Joe
Biden's quid pro quo he seems to think
you are wrong Destiny is completely
wrong he's biased
um there's there's no question when you
like there's no honest assessment where
you can look at Devin Archer saying we
were selling the brand of the bidens and
Joe Biden's on the phone that's Hunter
bidenberg Executives called DC because
the prosecutor was putting pressure on
us and then Joe Biden went and got the
prosecutor fired there's no sane
reasonable person who is being honest
who can say that Joe Biden's intentions
were completely coincidental I think
somebody who happened to be that way
whoops that the prosecutor was so bad he
wouldn't fire anybody so they got rid of
him that's just nonsense because the
prosecutor they brought in shut down all
the all the investigations so barisma is
being investigated by Victor Shogun
Hunter Biden and the execs call DC do
you see which Devin Archer I guess was
implying it was in innuendo for Carl
Biden Joe Biden's on the phone with
Hunter and his business partners there
is no way Joe did not know what was
going on Joe then flies personally to
Ukraine and says fire the prosecutor or
else they make this argument where
they're like but the what Richard
shulkin wasn't doing the investigations
that's why he had to get rid of him and
then I'm like and then after they got
rid of shoken they brought in someone
who is solid says Joe Biden and that guy
who was solid shut down the
investigations into brisma then when
Donald Trump got on the phone with I
think it was poroshenko at the time I'm
not sure and he said what's going on
with this this video that's going we see
this video of Joe Biden saying this what
is this I'd like it if you can look into
this let people know you're looking into
it and then what happens my
colaslachevsky the founder of resnuff
flees the country again
that's weird he had fled the country
when Victor shulkin was investigating
when choking gets removed he comes back
when Donald Trump steps in he flees the
country again
no sane rational person who's being
honest is is gonna is gonna believe that
Joe Biden was doing something honestly
we gotta have Destiny back on and by the
way don't lie to me admitted this on
video after the Obama Administration he
literally got on stage and was like yeah
we threatened to withhold money if they
didn't if they didn't fire this
prosecutor and man within an hour it
happened like it he said it himself well
you said it you said it right there yeah
this isn't even inference like you said
it and the response people give on the
left is but it was the policy of the
United States and it's like okay so the
vice president can threaten to withhold
congressionally approved loan guarantees
if the U.S sets the policy yes so then
why was Donald Trump impeached because
you claimed he had no authority to
withhold congressionally approved loan
guarantees but Donald Trump is the
president and sets the policy just like
Joe Biden said call the president
he'll tell you
it's nonsense they're lying and I think
I I think Destiny just cannot be on the
in this instance you know Trump was
right Camp good I wanna I wanna know
that'll be a good conversation
like for Destiny to watch the car right
now thing and be like Oh plain as day
here's the truth like I I trust him
for him to say this about Joe Biden he's
clearly missing information
very clearly he's just not Michael
malice on uh you are welcome didn't see
the whole episode look pretty fun that
sounds like probably a really really
good episode because Destiny's really
smart yeah I'd love I should watch that
actually I'd love to see one comment
said it was the most contentious episode
they'd ever seen where no one was
getting angry they were like
that sounds like both Michael and
doesn't it sounds really good yeah
Matt Shear says it's my 25th birthday
and I gotta love being able to listen to
y'all hey thanks for the Super Chat and
happy birthday yeah I appreciate you
sending us a present on your birthday
Alistair vusen says Justin Trudeau's
wife is leaving him for a real man like
Ian Crossland the nature of men and
women can't be ignored yes and you're
gonna read that one
I got him what's happening here it's uh
I'm not gonna talk about that
in public
Leon Yoder says Marlene Barbera is
fighting cancer she was dropped by her
Portland health clinic for transphobia
after staff at her clinic saw a private
message to her to her doctor where she
criticized a trans flag inside the
clinic leftists on X are celebrating
cold Civil War
yup yeah I saw that story that's like
I mean This Woman's undergoing cancer
treatment oh they don't care yeah they
don't care verden jorgea says the
difference between U.S and French
Revolution was the Rights of Man versus
the rights of men we're centered on the
individual there's entered on class we
the people as individuals versus we the
collective people that's why you could
be an enemy of the people very
interesting but I do think it's
important to recognize that hyper
individualism is what brings us to where
we are today because nobody knows their
neighbors anymore and they mind their
own business and they don't form
communities and defend those communities
double-edged sword double edged
moving on
we will grab some more Super chats
8-bit Poltergeist says sometimes when
deleted videos or photos are recovered
the file can become readable but may be
corrupted possible choppy footage
explanation Perhaps Perhaps Perhaps
let's grab oh here's a good one David
magdalino says Tim is it just me or did
Big Daddy government give the green
light to YouTube to lift the ban on
speaking about j6 so they could indict
Trump unless they ban literally all of
the news podcasts
it was already bad enough when they I
think it was um breaking points with uh
uh Sagar and uh Crystal they got
suspended once because they played a
clip of trump at a rally or something
like that and Trump said something with
the election I think it was them they
might have been it might have been Hill
Rising I think they're on the hill at
the time I'm not sure before the left
yeah yeah or maybe it wasn't them I
don't know I'm pretty sure they got they
got targeted by it
loyal Snoop Doge says I'm legally blind
due to an optic nerve issue from birth
Lasik won't work on me my only hope for
normal vision is neuralink but even then
I'm still extremely skeptical no I
totally get that
the first thing that's going to happen
is people who get norlink are going to
be people who need medical treatment
paralyzed they're going to be like well
neural link can help you you're going to
have any kind of like nerve damage from
disease or anything optic uh your ears
or whatever auditory yeah auditory
they're going to say you know neural
link can can help correct this problem
yeah I think the first thing you'll see
is going to be curing paralysis stem
cells can help but also neuralink and
neurolink might be the fastest way to do
it they'll say stem cells can take years
you know you get the injection it could
be months a lot of Rehabilitation with
neurolink the connection is
instantaneously applied and you should
be walking within a month or two once
you like get the signals and figure it
out everything people are going to
immediately do that but then the people
who get the neural link for that are
going to start talking about not only do
they have the ability to walk but now
they can just think the internet
something like that will happen like
data feed sent to their brains Community
terrifying sentence I can think the
internet like I can see where that would
feel so great to some people inside
yeah true it's like turning your
thoughts off legma says for Ian's
question Israel was a heavily socialist
country and they did away with it in the
80s and became capitalist the current
political turmoil there is the Socialist
dominated overly powered Supreme Court
not wanting to give up its unfairly
Consolidated powers
interesting yeah I've heard that they
wanted to get rid of the Israeli Supreme
Court that's wild I don't know a lot
about it I didn't know it was a
socialist Supreme Court but to think
that a country is going to get rid of
its Supreme Court is pretty freakish
Yugi says I think that Ian would love
the anime Psychopaths it's about a
computer that can read your mental state
and it can flag you as a latent criminal
and the police will arrest you dude you
gotta learn how to meditate with no
thought because that kind of stuff can
be real they can they can people can
track your thought patterns you got to
have none there's a funny uh new episode
of Biebs and Butthead because they're
doing the new season and uh they're
meditating with their hippie teacher and
he's like clear your mind to reach a
higher mental state and then because
they have nothing in their brains they
just instantly Elevate
there's like a bunch of religious
leaders are there and like Buddha is
there
yeah because they call all sorts of
problems I saw that alcohol was getting
me there but it wasn't the same kind of
no thought it was just a a different
kind of no thought
all right what's this essay federally
says to her point I remember to this day
my mother was held held up at the pay
Point while nurses took us to a room
before shots they acted rushed poked our
ears and wiped swabs we cried
hysterically they drew blood and dipped
mom says didn't happen what is this in
reference to you were saying I think
this is a reference to when Liz said
that uh as a mom you're told not to
question the people yeah
they're acting like you're wasting their
time I think is what he's saying
yeah I mean it's kind of crazy actually
when you have a baby at first you go
into the pediatrician and they just like
any question you have they're just like
the science can't question it you're
crazy we'll fire you if you don't do
what we say like they're not
collaborative at all did you tell them
to buzz off yeah I fired my pediatrician
wow but that but they're hard because
especially if you live I don't know how
rurally living is but like you can run
out of Pediatricians you can end up
driving big distances I do yeah yeah
all right major seller says by her
definition aliens have ever encountered
would not be sentient and wouldn't
deserve rights
you ready for this aliens are just
demons
but what so like if what if aliens show
up in like a big spaceship would you
just be like their demons go away that's
what I think it is all that's what I
think all these spotting of these holy
water here we go yeah exactly let me
bless you
um no I think it's just demons I think
it's demons I don't think that I think
the idea of extraterrestrials coming
from Mars is like a figment of someone's
imagination that's what I'm saying like
who invented that like why do we think
of a flying saucer and Little Green Men
because that was science fiction someone
invented that like why is that more real
to people than something that's
invisible but that throughout human
history we've acknowledged as well
there's no spiritual battle around us I
think it's demons that are no one's
saying the UFOs right now are coming
from Mars specifically I mean some
people might say Mars specifically but
Mars isn't the the main Contender for
where the aliens may come from if they
are other planets other universes I mean
reticuli I think is what they told
babies I mean but it came from like the
Martians right yeah like that's the
whole story that was like like saying
that came from Mars is just because Mars
is visible to the naked eye right that's
kind of I wonder if there's anything
else on other planet but when we talk
about the greater concept of
extraterrestrial life extraterrestrial
just means outside of Earth so would you
say that a demon is an extraterrestrial
yes yes a demon a demon born of another
plane would be by definition
extraterrestrial terrestrial of course
referring to Earth and extra meaning
outside of or Beyond okay
defining this more precisely than the
general public but what I'm saying is
the general public isn't coming out
saying the aliens all came from Mars
what do you think no but they're saying
that they're cut they came from they're
like life forms from other planets or
other galaxies or other dimensions or
from I don't I haven't heard very many
people saying other dimensions saying
that they're like oh it's part of the
spiritual battle Alex Jones was it four
years five years ago they're saying
they're interdimensional beings but that
ties in with the demon concept like if
something if it's a pattern of energy
that's manipulating mental States like
that could be pervasive throughout the
system let's talk about demons and let's
we'll talk more about this in the
members only because I got a lot of
things to ask but I want to read some
more Super chats I think it'll be a
really good conversation
Chad Shin says Hey guys great show
tonight I'm starting a YouTube Rumble
Channel streaming 5m Farm Sim 22 and
other games plus was wondering if you
needed a handyman around your compound
if so where could I apply we just hired
a handyman oh nice literally just hired
handyman I don't know if we're
announcing yet I can't wait I think I
know who it is but yeah I'm gonna like
everyone here already knows who it is
yeah and everybody who watches the show
knows who it is I got a picture with it
they don't know that we hired them
congrats my dude
but I I I I'm not going to say anything
until I have like the I don't know who's
doing what yeah yeah no it's really a
fascinating moment a profound uh um a
profound moment in my life is when the
first time a thing happened at timcast
that I had nothing to do with it was a
crazy thing for me because like when the
when the company first starts like I'm
running everything everything and then
one day I walk in to like the office and
I see this like binder of like Tim cast
policy procedure and stuff and I was
like
not only did I have nothing to do with
it I didn't even know anyone was going
to be doing it and it's just they're
like whoa like things are being made not
people are getting hired I don't even is
that nice like that we have grown to a
point where like you don't have to be
involved in everything or does it feel
weird
I don't know I don't know I just it's
it's a it's an experience to be like oh
wow look at that like it's doing its own
thing now level of trust with your
employees I know I feel like when that
happens for me I'm it's like a
Bittersweet thing right part of me is
like proud because I'm like great you
know delegate people do things it
becomes its thing and part of me is like
what if it has my name on it and I don't
like it yeah
I think that must be really hard
all right we will grab some more Super
chats
Stephen Wolfe says Tim cast and Joe
Rogan should host the debates 2024. 100
I would never host any kind of debate
they do
but in the in the sense of
Tim Kess and Joe Rogan should have put
presidential candidates on their show
sometimes together it's a very very good
idea
I think Joe is um
the reason why Joe Rogan's show was so
important is that he knows so much about
so much
and uh
he can he can provide a general audience
seeking entertainment especially when it
comes to like MMA fans who just like
watching a show with general knowledge
of things the mainstream press does not
give people and then what we have here
is probably similar politics but hyper
esoteric and hard for the general public
so if you really wanted to have like a
good debate that would reach the most
people it would be Joe Rogan with like
two different candidates on and them
just talking
I think if we did it like the stuff
we're talking about with Joe Biden
barisma is going to go over the heads of
the average person like we should do it
but it's for a politically minded
audience if you're trying to win votes
and trying to expose you know the
average person to new ideas Joe Rogan
clearly is the guy and I think it was
Patrick Bet David was telling him to
have Trump on oh good Joe you got to do
it you gotta have Trump on the show
because Trump's been wanting to go on
Trump trump I think Trump would do in a
heartbeat apparently he's wanted to do
it and Joe was talking about how he
would ask him about the Deep State about
the inner workings of politics what it's
like when you get in there and those are
the questions that matter yeah Joe was
saying before his concern was that he
would help Trump or whatever yeah and
I'm like here's my view I don't care if
it helps or hurts we don't invite people
on this show because it might help them
you know people are like thank you for
having the show really hard and I'm like
I don't know whatever like you're a
person doing a thing we want to hear
from you you know what I mean Donald
Trump being asked questions by Joe will
be deeply enlightening yeah very very
good it would be good for our country
like if people understood how the Deep
State worked yeah
uh let's see Dolan Tire says get Dave
Rubin for protestantis oh yeah I saw
that oh that's a good idea actually
I don't but the problem with Dave hosts
his own show right we can't be like hey
Dave stop doing your show and come do
ours instead it's like that's not fair
it's not a fair question I saw a uh chat
that sings Steve Dees I don't know if he
supports the scientist openly but
I think Reuben is on his August break so
he might come on hey you're on vacation
would you come back I mean like it's
interesting
I got a feeling he's gonna say something
like he takes these breaks for a reason
you know what I mean that's fair that is
fair that kids I think right recently of
kids you know and I think it's one thing
about taking my month off was like
Health behind the scenes stuff like
debating Laura yeah yeah not traveling
to DC to debate someone in the most
intense debate you can imagine
yo I I I don't know I'll come back on I
gotta tell you it's gonna be like didn't
even get the invite I think what will
happen is most of the Santa's people we
reach out to will refuse to do it
because it's Laura Loomer yeah as soon
as you announced who it was I was like
oh there are a bunch of people who are
like nothing I'm out later and they're
gonna go running there's got to be
people that are would love to do it
because it's Laura Loomer too hopefully
yeah yeah maybe but the thing is Laura's
going to have
an encyclopedic knowledge of things that
I mean she's like looking into the the
high school records of the donors she's
going to be so intense
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member so that you can watch the
uncensored members only showed we posted
on the front page of the website
probably about four or five minutes and
we're talking about angels demons aliens
and moral philosophy and what this
country needs in terms of religion and
spirituality it's going to be a lot of
fun you can follow the show at
timcastirl basically everywhere you can
follow me personally at timcast
everywhere follow me on X and Instagram
Liz you want to shout anything out oh I
can't call it X follow me on Twitter at
Liz underscore Twitter
um buy my new book it's out in just a
couple weeks
hideyourchildrenbook.com I think you
guys are gonna love it some of you are
gonna hate it and I want to hear
everybody's thoughts on it so
hideyourchildrenbook.com are you sending
it to people for like reviews and stuff
yeah you want a copy yes I do I'd be
happy to send you one we haven't gotten
it yet or I would have brought one I
love when people give me books I'm in
um but yeah I'm so glad you're here it's
so fun to see you uh I'm Hannah Claire
Grimlock I'm a writer for timcast.com
you should follow at timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram maybe you'll see
my review of Liz's book uh and if you
want to follow me personally you can
follow me on Twitter at HC brimlow and
on Instagram at handclare.b
x marks the spot I was waiting all night
all day yeah work it out uh follow me on
X Eddie and Crossland and anywhere else
Eddie and crosland I'm happy to see you
Liz happy that you guys are listening
and being a part of this wild freaking
ride man what a time to be alive I'm
glad we got the internet because it's
cool to document it as we go all right
see you later indeed uh yeah Twitter me
it's still Twitter on my on my phone so
tweet me
um that's better to say to argue there
that on X it sounds weird to say let's
argue One X just I don't know anyways
yeah follow me uh on Twitter on
Instagram I'm search.com see you guys
later we will see you all over at
timcast.com in a few minutes thanks for
hanging out